l'animal avec les 0 1
je compte pas en augmentant la à je suis
président la république moi je suis à
paris m'a tapé trop chaud cet été
si j'ai failli y passer fo jl il était
bien il était frais rien je t'ai connu
plus de roland
[Musique]
bah
terre
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission où tout le monde parle avec
nous ce soir on en fait non pas parce
que là c'est juste comme ça
pourquoi pourquoi d'ailleurs à couper
pourquoi t'as pas enchaîné parce que on
a dit qu'on faisait des répètes et tout
mais il y avait une sorte de grâce le
public était beau tout était bon fallait
y aller quoi tu vas leur faire des
tâches ils vont être moche mais on est
content
qu'est-ce qu'on fait frédéric bon ben on
va la garder un bon aller avec nous ce
soir
besancenot
monaco va
fabien galthié
[Applaudissements]
révélations sur la mort de ben laden
sophie thalmann
la smera
cindy lauper
l'action sur ben laden
wozniak
elles l'ont fait
[Musique]
bonsoir l'an bonsoir et merci bonsoir ça
va la vie pour toi en ce moment tu te
fatigue pas trop un t shirt wa
tranquille peinard
rien de spécial à faire en ce moment
c'est la période de repos c'est marrant
il en fallait tu te laisse vivre en ce
moment oui complètement la wii la pousse
pas dans les émissions de télé est rien
rien du tout regard ailleurs la
préparation voilà on te dire si je me
sens concerné mais reconnecter avec la
france allah allah ça marche ça ça comme
un merci à nos amis téléspectateurs et
puis des cartes de bons clients laurent
les cartes de bons clients toujours
taton berdot si des fois voilà c'est une
[ __ ] qui me gave un peu blaireau
qu'il ya un mot plus haut que l'autre
[Musique]
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici al hajj ali et olivier besancenot
voilà en laye jaggy olivier besancenot
merci d'être la première
un plateau ensemble alors
[Applaudissements]
enough is enough
bravo pour cette union dont on y va
c'est la première fois que vous êtes sur
un plateau de télévision ensemble il
faut le dire à billets et abitibi merci
d'avoir choisi tout le monde en parle on
en est très fier pour l'heureuse
nouvelle
alors sa différence d'âge ça pose des
problèmes politiques non et voilà donc
la lcr et lo sont d'accord pour
présenter des listes communes aux
élections régionales et robert également
d'accord pour baisser la clim vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure ça fait partie
du programme
ça fait partie du programme brand à
antonio il faut voilà évidemment ça a
l'air très beau comme ça on se dit ça y
est ils ont reçu une espèce
d'illumination du saint-esprit bien que
ça soit pas trop votre truc mais on this
est formidable et puis on découvre qu'en
fait c'est cette union que l'on croit
d'amour est en fait un mariage de raison
c'est parce que la loi électorale a
changé et qu'en fait on n'est plus dans
le proportionnel mais dans le scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours et donc je
voulais être présent au deuxième tour il
faut vous mettre d'accord non je crois
que c'est un accord politique c'est pas
en accord électoralistes wen s'est
retrouvé nos deux organisations et puis
d'autres assez présent à s'est
rassemblée pour les mobilisations
sociales du printemps sur la question
des retraites notamment
et puis on est présents ensemble dans
nos nombreux combats sociaux dont on a
des divergences mais on n'a plus de
point commun que de divergences faisait
découvrir je viens même programme sur
beaucoup de choses évidemment puisqu'on
a manifesté coup droit vous avez attendu
que la loi change pour vous mettre
d'accord il ya longtemps que j'ai
programmé cette loi est fait pour
empêcher les petits partis d'obtenir des
élus la part à 10%
elle était fait pour ça donc à parti
démocratique saveurs de la loi n'est pas
et antidémocratique
absolument et de ce point de vue là
effectivement peut-être les électeurs
nous aiderons t-il à franchir cette
barre des 10% pour être présent au
second tour
d'accord sur les photos officielles
'cela fait que c'est la photo pour les
mairies voilà
merci donc olivier le 2 novembre la lcr
a donné son accord à des listes communes
non sans mal parce qu'il y avait
certains militants qui avaient rejoint
la lcr après le 21 avril et qui
comprennent mal l'association de la lcr
avec l'eau d'arlette laguiller qui a
quand même refusé d'appeler à voter
chirac le au deuxième tour il ya eu des
dissensions et des débats dans notre
organisation on a eu une discussion
démocratique à tous nos militants qui
sont prononcés entre autres sur cet
accord à l'occasion notre congrès et il
ya effectivement 30% de nos militants
qui sont prenez se prononcer contre cet
accord là mais là dedans y'a pas que des
nouveaux militants ça si je dresse c'est
un vieux débat entre nous parce que
parce que c'est une question qui se pose
effectivement régulièrement je crois
aussi bien à l'occasion des élections
qu'à l'occasion des luttes et c'est pour
ça que c'est important de comprendre
qu'il ya quand même quelque chose qui se
passe entre arlette et moi entre lutte
ouvrière et la lcr c'est aussi des
rapports militants constante c'est pas
seulement un combat continu comme
claudia schiffer n'ont pas tout à fait
c'est passé pas l'île de la tentation
donc s'est pas laissée faire entendre
une voix
la clim voilà le message et princesses
on est très efficace et bien ça sent bon
votre histoire
ils sont jeunes les plus forts dès
qu'ils sont deux des filins clim est
coupée à peu près de fort alors
imaginons la queue dans ces élections
qui se préparent à un moment le front
national soit en passe de gagner
est ce que vous faites vous appeler à
voter contre lui quand même on a décidé
que effectivement là où le front
national serait en passe de gagner une
région on appellerait à voter pour la
gauche que pour la droite alors lutte
ouvrière n'a pas encore pris cette
décision c'est le 6 et 7 décembre c'est
votre congrès ça peut être rejetée non
non non c'est plus que ça non non ça va
être un défi
ce n'est dans la préparation de notre
congrès bien sûr qu'il ya des réticences
pour les raisons opposées sur la
différence d'âge quand même joue pas
pour les raisons opposées à celles de la
lcr mais je pense qu'on aura une large
majorité à notre congrès je sait pas
encore de combien
c'est le congrès alors moins 70 cela bah
oui j'espère moi 70 pour se présenter
ensemble
qu'est ce que vous avez déjà couché
ensemble non je gardais mais laissez le
pineau non est-ce que vous avez déjà un
coup sûr en compte vos idées sur le
papier c'est à dire vous avez déjà placé
il ya un protocole d'accord il ya une
profession de foi commune pour dire aux
élections dites moi a qu à cause
d'arlette comme la lcr s'écarte un peu
plus de la grande famille de gauche
parce qu'avant il y avait quand même des
passerelles entre la lcr la gauche
socialiste y avait beaucoup de gens des
lacs sont passés au ps
est ce que finalement vous n'êtes pas en
train de vous faire comme ça je le
récupère et par lutte ouvrière
séduit par arlette laguiller mais de
toute façon il serait pas terrible je
sais de toute façon je crois que à
gauche c'est une vraie rupture que ça se
court pour lutte ouvrière ou les cerfs
vis-à-vis tout l'ex gauche plurielle qui
continue à maintenir le même cap c'est à
dire qu'ils continuent à nous faire
croire qu'on pourrait accompagner plus
ou moins socialement le libéralisme
moi j'ai jamais eu de passerelles haut
niveau ce quelconque avec un
strauss-kahn - fa bus qui par exemple
privatiser la poste a et le vélo oui est
ce qui va devenir le vélo le vélo de jg
il va être privatisée levé le fourmilier
il faut en parler parce que pour rigoler
de 6000 bureaux de poste qui qui vont
qui vont être supprimés la cour des
comptes qui se transforme en espèces de
conseiller financier du patronat a
expliqué texto que le réseau de
distribution était surdimensionné donc
j'ai traduit pour que ça soit simple ça
veut dire qu'il va y avoir des bureaux
de poste qui vont sauter en pagaille
dans les quartiers populaires et dans
les zones rurales parce qu'ils sont plus
rentables et concrètement ces 6000
bureaux qu'il s'agit de faire
disparaître adéquat sur le rmi
la tps j'avais envie de lire cette
phrase ça va peut-être mettre la quitte
a raison ça booste les neurones or on
vous trouve tous très sympathiques
arrêté et olivier mais quand on commence
à parler de votre programme des fois ça
fait un peu froid dans le dos donc en
prendre un certain nombre de points
et vous allez me dire si c'est ça ou si
c'est pas ça par exemple interdiction
des licenciements dans les entreprises
en particulier les entreprises qui font
des profits et celles qui font pas de
profit celles qui font pas de profit ses
sous réserve d'inventaire
où est passé l'argent donc ça veut dire
eh oui ça veut dire control contrôle des
comptes en banque contrôle des
travailleurs parce que toutes les
violences
je dis ça parce que les choses soient
sincères fois dans les toilettes et
olivier sont géniaux sauf qu'il faut
savoir que si vous êtes au pouvoir
vous viendrez liorac wade qui va venir
vérifier les comptes des entreprises si
les travailleurs avaient accès au compte
de leur propre entreprise serait déjà
pas mal et je crois qu'on pourrait
démontrer que les licenciements ne sont
pas justifiées et que bien souvent on
licencie simplement pour augmenter les
dividendes des actionnaires et il n'y a
aucune raison il n'y a aucune raison que
ce soit toujours les travailleurs qu'ils
fassent les frais d' c'était comique où
tout est basé on va sur le probable et
donc l'interdiction des licenciements
oui surtout dans les entreprises qui
font des bénéfices et même dans celles
qui n'en feraient pas si des fois
l'argent était un petit peu consacré
acheter d'autres des manteaux de
fourrure la femme du patron voilà
beaucoup d'entreprises tandis qu'elles
vont supprimer des emplois
parce qu'elles vont mal appartiennent à
des grands groupes est en réalité font
des produits donc tout ça il faudrait
pouvoir alors ensuite création de
centaines de milliers d'emplois dans
l'administration et les services publics
oui bah oui au contraire à un pays où
tout le monde et quatre autres que
génère quand même mais attendez ceux qui
disent ça ils n'ont pas besoin de se
faire soigner à l'hôpital
ils savent pas qu'on manque
d'infirmières bordant
donc on pourrait créer des milliers de
fonctionnaires en plus bas par exemple
dans la santé ça peut être tout de suite
maintenant 120 1120 parce que les
syndicats comme ça mais oui mais
honnêtement s'il tolère de la canicule
je m'excuse mais la canicule c'est vrai
qu'on ne pouvait pas le prévoir
ma force de fermer des lits d'hôpitaux
et de refuser d'embaucher depuis des
années des années ce gouvernement comme
le précédent bas effectivement ça même
sans la canicule la nuit dans les
hôpitaux il ya deux infirmières pour
quatre étages en continu au ch de
salaire alors là vous allez augmenter
les salaires
nous on y pour lire que les salaires
augmentent même dans l'audiovisuel
bombardier au visuel mais si on ne sait
pas si facile à henri peut-être sagement
vous pensez sérieusement c'est très
important
vous pensez que le salaire minimum en
france devait être de combien mettant le
minimum que quelqu'un gagne
écoutez le minimum c'est ses 1500 euros
quand même c'est par jour mais oui bien
sûr alors
vous êtes comme un maximum non j'imagine
oui 1600 euros c'est bien sincèrement
quand on voit le peu d'augmentation de
salaire pour dire pas du tout d'ailleurs
pour les fonctionnaires 0 en 2003 05
début 2015
quand on voit à côté de ça effectivement
toute hâte à 2 2 p dg qui ont des
salaires énormes stocks comme moi aussi
il y aurait besoin de la forcer à
combien imaginons c'est très bien
olivier comme moi que ça ça sera l'objet
de luttes et qu' il faudra effectivement
se bagarrer pour obtenir ça et on verra
bien dans le le décours de la lutte ce
que décideront les travailleurs ce qui
revêt les travailleuses notre programme
ce dernier n'est pas d'occasion pour le
prochain programme c'est pas d'écrire
pour le prochain programme électoral les
fiches de paye de chacun et chacune
ouais simplement c'est de réduire au
maximum ils établirent légal il aurait
serré l'éventail des salaires j'imagine
qu'on me retire rien de quoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui 80% de la population qui
vit avec 1200 euros par mois et le pdg
de l'oréal il va gagner en une seule
minute parce que j'ai vraiment rien ne
pourra pas gagner toute sa vie donc
c'est écoeurant
donc cela la répartition des richesses
on peut la faire
alors on va regarder un petit peu
rapidement comme ça s'écrit pdg de
l'oréal pour dire qu'ils gagnent
beaucoup plus si vous étiez au pouvoir
tous les deux imaginant qui dirigerait
le pays il y aura un président un public
où il y aura un comité aurait des
comités dans les entreprises des comités
de quartier avaient invité des virages
et le pouvoir central commun il y aura
un pouvoir sans qu'ils seront bien sûr
ça je sais pas parce qu'il peut être à
paris il peut être à lille il peut être
n'importe où et combien de partis
politiques du set pour le pluralisme
quand même tous les partis politiques
pour être autorisée il aurait pas de
financement des besoins des grandes
entreprises
ça serait peut-être que les as en mer
dont les leaders des partis devraient
peut-être aller distribuer des tracts à
la porte des zones de prendre chez nous
le front national sera autorisée
je sais je crois pas que le front
national ce soit un problème
d'interdiction a je crois que de toute
façon si le front national était
interdite il existerait d'une façon plus
claire des styles peut-être plus
dangereuses dans les mesures concrètes
aussi au niveau démocratique on pourrait
estimer que non seulement les élus sont
pas amenés à faire je sais pas combien
de mandat au cours de leur vie c'est à
dire faire en sorte que la politique
devienne pas un métier vous êtes
d'accord avec sarkozy vous dites qu'au
bout de sarkozy la wii 2 chirac au bout
de six accords gilani treuil mots il ya
la question du salaire qui est parce que
si on veut que la politique devienne pas
un métier précisément ben moi je vois
pas pourquoi pourquoi ce conte des
mandats gagne plus que ceux qui sont
censés représenter c'est à dire la
majorité de la rencontre avec combien
d'heures par semaine pas écoutés nous
déjà 35 heures elle était appliquée
partout sans réduction de salaire sans
flexibilité sans annualisation du temps
de travail ça serait déjà pas mal
peut-être que on estimerait que pour que
tout le monde ait un emploi
faudrait peut-être travailler moins il
partagé et et le travail
l'ensemble des richesses de travail
qu'il faudrait pour tout le monde et en
emplois voilà c'est ça en fait
saleh
moi qui suis vieille militante et bien
quand je manifestais des années 60 68
ont réclamé les 30 heures 30 heure mais
réclamait alors est ce que ce serait à
chacun selon ses besoins
oui oui c'est ce qu'ont gros besoins
comment il ferait alors bas ça fait
jaser panique
non je crois pas que les besoins de
chacun je crois que chacun aspire à
avoir de quoi vivre à pouvoir profiter
de loisirs
maintenant le gars qui peut ou la fille
qui peut pas vivre sans avoir trois
voitures différentes par exemple voient
la maison dans dix endroits différents
dans le temps figé a permis tant pis
pour eux by van on may sera obligée de
ses excédents sérieusement déjà
quelqu'un me demande déjà que tout le
monde ait un logement un logement
correct ou à des jeux justement parce
que dans ce pays le droit au logement
d'ailleurs dans toute l'europe le droit
au logement
il est même pas respect jusqu'au mans le
droit au logement est ce que vous êtes
pour la réouverture des maisons closes
non pas les amener par ce biais là parce
que sur la question du logement il ya
une autre loi une vraie loi celle là
elle existe c'est pas celle des maisons
closes c'est celle de la réquisition des
logements vides et cette fois là elle
est toujours pas appliquée parce qu'il
ya eu aucun gouvernement qui a eu pour
appliquer la loi le courage de
s'embrouiller ne serait ce qu'un tout
petit peu avec les spéculateurs
immobiliers par exemple donc quand on
parle des besoins et ses marges aux gens
de bien et fort beaucoup de mal absolu
et les besoins faut essayer des sériés
parce qu'il ya des besoins sociaux qui
sont fondamentaux élémentaire se loger
se nourrir se soigner
est ce que finalement
chirac vous utilisent pas un petit peu
comme mitterrand utiliser le front
national c'est à dire que finalement
vous l'aidez chirac parce que vous
emmerder le ps donc il est peinard comme
mitterrand tant que le fn emmerder la
droite il était peinard est-ce que c'est
pas un peu le même le même schéma je
sais pas si on emmerde le ps mais ce que
je sais si ceux ci ont fait beaucoup de
voix on va sacrément bt le patronat mais
ça me gonfle un peu cette histoire parce
qu'on l'entend depuis pas mal de temps
là l'histoire de les les pantins qui
sont un peu c'est à dire qu'il ya la
droite qui se met derrière alors la
droite quand même moi je me rappelle de
ce que disait gouvernement ce que disait
chirac le printemps dernier on n'était
pas en odeur de sainteté quand même
c'était la grande thème d'ailleurs c'est
complètement délirant c'était le thème
de la manipulation de l'extrême gauche
alors que c'est évidemment beaucoup plus
large que ça et puis je crois que de
toute façon nous notre objectif c'est de
construire une opposition crédible sur
des bases effectivement anticapitaliste
de défense des travailleurs à ce
gouvernement là parce que ce
gouvernement pour l'instant défend la
politique patronale
or après que ça emmerde le ps parce que
le ps au spa aujourd'hui ne serait-ce
que reprendre les revendications de la
rue c'est son problème mais qu'on nous
accuse pas à nous pas de claire par
rapport à cette question là nous on est
là pour se coltiner seiller
alors les clés billets et olivier
besancenot vous êtes les représentants
de l'extrême gauche
vous ne serez pas étonné qu'on fasse une
interview ouzou
[Musique]
alors j'ai voulu citer un certain nombre
de deux noms du ou semi politique et
vous allez me dire comme ça rapidement
quelle réaction vous avez sur eux
sarkozy arlette sarkozy je pense qui
fait de la démagogie sécuritaire
démagogie sécurité la pensée qu'il est
président ça j'en sais rien moi je
voterai pas pour lui c'est pareil
raffarin arlette raffarin va écouter
peut-être pas tirer sur les ambulances
j'ai l'impression que ça n'a pas très
bien pour lui que sa cote de popularité
est en baisse c'est bien fait vite les
mauvais coups contre la classe ouvrière
il est viré arlette oui c'est pas cool
pour lui il va perdre son emploi tu vas
pas le défendre
non non mais il a en poitou la balle
doit avoir de croix se reconvertir tu
penses qu'il avait mis de côté
raffarin rivière basse et la boîte de
communication du medef c'est à dire qui
laisse apparaître les seuils de mettre
en mots simples des politiques qui vont
nous faire très très mal et deux
ensembles polluants la piale 22 moi j'ai
rien
allez vous
bon bayrou olivier béraud j'ai vu ces
petites déclarations il fait on ne peut
plus dans le social en ce moment c'est
de faire oublier que sa politique c'est
libéralisme donc scellé privatisation de
services publics ça les fonds de pension
sur les retraites c'est l'armé blanche
df est quand même dans le gouvernement
hélène ségara olala quoi pour hélène
ségara la suite à des revenus
si elle arrive à emporter ce ballon elle
est venue pour ça qu'elle est venue
hélène ségara oui on aime est parti je
n'en ai d'ailleurs j'adore je vous dis
franchement nous tranquilles m 1 non non
mais je suis sûr pourquoi parce que j'ai
pas trop le loisir de d'écouté de la
star ac toi tu étais toujours bloquée
complètement mais enfin quand tu zappes
tes boutons pour qui toi tu zappes quand
même tu vois bien aimé quand les
licenciements elle t'a dit donc voilà on
continue olivier carmarks bas karl marx
et il était là la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs ya un mot pour lui là bas
pour moi c'est c'est évidemment un grand
personnage dans l'histoire cac a permis
à un moment donné à la majorité de la
population de se dire on peut avoir un
projet d'émancipation on peut avoir un
projet de société alternatif et puis
évidemment je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser qu'on a dit tout tout et
n'importe quoi sur lui et que sa pensée
a été utilisé dans une dictature
sanglante au cours du siècle dernier qui
était la dictature stalinienne mais cas
rien à voir pour moi avec le marxisme
c'est l'idée de l'égalité sociale et la
démocratie totale et sans limites pour
moi d'accord castro c'est vrai que
castro comme beaucoup de leaders
nationalistes comme mao ou apporter des
choses à leur peuple
la santé l'éducation et où il ya
beaucoup de gens là sont des
l'hiver la santé l'éducation et que et
que cuba pas grand chose à voir avec un
certain nombre de pays pauvres de ce
point de vue là même quand c'est moins
bien sûr j'ai quand même mais bien sûr
je suis pas d'accord évidemment avec le
manque de liberté politique
il a du sang sur les mains il ya à cuba
oui oui certainement du sens en tout cas
il ay la fed et il a du sang pendant la
révolution enfin les américains
n'avaient encore plus non mais là n'est
aujourd'hui ils ont déjà aujourd'hui
encore mode c'est inadmissible que pour
simplement exprimer exprimer son
opposition des gens soient en taule pour
20 ans ou 22 d'accord si on est du côté
des cubes alors combat général de dire
que un socialisme à visage humain ça
peut peut-être existé donc moi c'est
bientôt che guevara de castro voilà là
je te mets à 8 parce que tu as bien
parlé george bush en vitesse
c'est un règne internationale au service
de la voir le compagnie c'est vrai que
ça résume assez bien ce qu'il en train
de faire c'est quand même un criminel
pour le peuple irakien
même si
bien sûr ne regrette saddam hussein mais
c'est aux irakiens de diriger leur pays
orlando vous connaissez orlando c'est un
chanteur ils exigent des clips et là il
ya tout sur la table si il est venu
aussi bien continue ben laden ah ben
laden pour moi
cc
c'est aussi un criminel bien sûr un
moment il ya moins d'un petit moment
c'est bon parce que les gens ont peur
maintenant
bon on attribue un peu facilement
maintenant tout se passe à bombarder
toute attente à la poste
c'est vraiment mais je pense pas que ce
soit quelqu'un qui soit pour la
libération des peuples même pas des
peuples musulmans évidemment olivier
michel drucker bas un présentateur de
télé j'ai mon nom vous avez vous allez
fabriquer un dimanche après midi
c'est pourquoi sa conférence à charles
ix a dit nos gars sont si drôles et
slash connaît pas plus
[Musique]
rafa bus il fait de la moto il allait me
manger des carottes râpées ou leurs
jeunes il essaye de faire super jeune je
crois que c'est quand même toujours les
vieilles idées gouvernementales et que
fabius il sera du côté du patronat pas
du côté des travailleurs non je crois
que dominique strauss kahn pareil pareil
pour vous ne lâchez pas s'il essaye de
faire jeune lui mais pareil ils font
partie de ceux dans le parti socialiste
qui ont poussé à ce que le parti
socialiste tape à bras raccourcis à la
rentrée politique sur la gauche anti
capitaliste plutôt que de s'attaquer au
patronat par exemple parce que sur le
fond il pense vraiment qu à gauche le
choix c'est ça c'est square où on pense
que finalement les mutations
industrielles en cours on les accompagne
et puis on n'a pas le choix on va mettre
une pincée de social surtout ça soit il
ya une rupture plus radicale et dans ces
cas là s'est arrêtée olivier où ils ont
envie que le choix politique se pose
comme ça et du coup évidemment nous on
est en désaccord avec eux ce qui devait
s'arranger à ce qu'ils disent comme
sérieusement et u10 pour faire changer
les choses il faut être aux affaires
tant qu'on n'est pas aux affaires très
simple raconter ce qu'on va enfin
changer ce qu'ils disent c'est bien ça
se fait qu'ils ont perdu que la gauche
plurielle a perdu 2,4 millions de voix y
compris par
la changer les choses quand il était aux
affaires bah oui cinq ans pour le faire
et par exemple quand balladur a mis les
cotisations retraite dans le privé de 37
ans et demi à 40 ans ps qui a eu cinq
ans le pouvoir il n'a pas changé les
choses devraient revenir sur ce qu'elle
ait fait balladur et même maintenant ils
s'engagent pas à défaire ce que raffarin
a fait donc la confiance mais voilà on
n'a pas coupé conscience bien on
continue
mona ue alors j'ai franchement j'aime
blindé de chez blindés je te racheter
toi ton copain tellement comme ça elle
va nous le dira mais possible
[Musique]
mona bonsoir heureusement bruits pour
parler du sida en afrique parce qu'ils
auraient fait là pour aller crever
terminée c'est vrai qu'à amouda où vous
êtes d'accord vous incarnez quand même
la milliardaire cosmopolite vous
possédez 15 100 robes de haute couture
comment osez-vous mais c'est surtout
pour encourager cet arrêt
et des ah ok à ce qui continue parce
qu'ils vont préserver l'emploi dans la
haute couture que vous achetez des robes
en quoi alors
je l'aimé même pourquoi tu achètes
jamais de mcdo du temps fou des salariés
muna a racheté le bateau de tapis
qu'elle loue à des gens elle est l'hôte
tapie a déjà un bateau elle où le bateau
de tapis ya des gens pour un million
deux par semaine c'est ça je ne sais
plus en france en euro a du temps euros
160 217 1000 ha ouais à milan 4 n'a plus
le louer facilement très facilement
matin j'apporte de l'eau à votre moulin
à l'année ça fait combien ça alors en
toi qui compte bien en euros à la
semaine 52 x 1 millions de bombes à ça
fait beaucoup d'argent tirer alors bon
on fait beaucoup dans le mécénat me fait
beaucoup dans la charité c'est tout à
fait vrai tout à fait sérieux mais
charité bien ordonnée plus jusqu'à
fériés je vous ai jusqu'à soutenir les
listes et lo lcr aux prochaines
élections régionales et européennes et
au printemps 2004 mais une fois que je
comprends exactement quels sont les
objectifs 4 la charité c'est pareil que
vous y avez vous essayé dit mélenchon
s'est arrêté là juste il ajuste justice
pour la légaliser pour égalité pour
l'égalité la justice la liberté
l'indépendance oui madame faites gaffe
parce que tout le monde aime beaucoup
arlette et olivier mais si son pouvoir
ça va être dur fait gaffe 1 pour vous
les robes eelv on voulait prendre le
lieu c'est là le phocéa ça c'est sûr
qu'on va ils émettent sagement sous là
le phocéa cela devenir une maison de
retraite pour les salariés de la poste
du val de marne
pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas il ya plein
de château qu'on terminons la sécurité
sociale ont terminé pour faire y compris
des fêtes révolutionnaires
voilà dans la vraie question c'est
est-ce que le partage doit être
autoritaire où il ce qu'il doit être
basée sur le bon vouloir des gens en
fait c'est ça l'histoire ce qu'elle
donne beaucoup moon à moi j'ai dit
l'autre jour dans une soirée acheter une
ampoule comme ça cent mille francs elle
peut le faire
enfin ces cent mille balles qui vont
pour les pour les africaines atteints du
sida donc les très généreuses mouna mais
vous ce que vous proposez c'est un
partage autoritaire s'est dit
reconnaissant et le froid
nous on lui prendrait nous ce qu'on
propose pour le sida sait déjà qu'on que
les grands trusts pharmaceutiques donne
à ceux qui peuvent pas payer en afrique
enfin vous le savez bien sûr c'est
absolument une catastrophe aujourd'hui
l'afrique est en train de se vider de
ses habitants à cause du sida
des millions de femmes d'hommes
d'enfants qui meurent aujourd'hui du
sida et qui peuvent pas se soigner parce
que ils ont pas de quoi tout simplement
acheter les trithérapies tous je suis
pas une spécialiste
et donc c'est ça nous qu'on veut changer
que ces trusts arrête pour faire des
profits d'empêcher les gens de se
soigner dans les pays pauvres mais c'est
carrément criminel parce que quand dans
le cas de la mondialisation aujourd'hui
c'est pas simplement qu'on donne pas les
moyens c'est qu'en plus il ya un brevet
indécent qu'impose un monopole sur la
fabrication de ces médicaments et qui
fait qu'effectivement 80% des malades ou
pas accès à des médicaments qui
permettrait de traiter la maladie ça si
c'est pas écorcher parce que c'est alors
tout à fait alors moon a donc 6 en poule
qu'on voit là sont des ampoules appelé
ithemba ce que dira espoir elles sont
décorées par des femmes séropositives
dans les townships du cap ce qui leur
permet d'avoir des revenus fixes au
départ c'est une idée de civils varet et
cette année il a demandé à 30 styliste
de mode ou couturier de dessiner des
ampoules voilà donc les les prototypes
les dessins originaux ont été vendus aux
enchères
c'est là vous allez acheter une est
ensuite les séries seront vendus dans
les magasins en profitent ces femmes
africaines c'est ça l'ensemble boutiques
magasins aussi en europe
on l'espère
les étendre aux etats-unis l'année
prochaine merci mouna bravo un truc
alors est-ce que grâce à ça elle trouve
grâce à vos yeux vous avez vu confisquer
son bateau tout de suite ou non non non
écouter
moi je sais pas madame comment elle a
son argent si elle exploite des milliers
de travailleurs qu'elle licencie qu et
tout ça je sais pas si c'est ça
j'ai alors celle qui me quittes voilà si
c'est eux qui vous quittent cet autre
chose donc je veux pas discuter de ça se
fait particulier bon elle fait partie
des riches qui donne un peu moins en
l'air préoccupé je connais sans
frontières moon un clown sans frontières
oui ça je te laisse l'intitulé ce qui va
faire un chèque au bout et des amis et
c'était très bien et bon dans les pays
en guerre pour porter des spectacles aux
enfants qui sont les vrais sujets comme
c'est pété de thunes serait bien qu'ils
fassent un chez costa
rohmer
merci mona mais le rêve il vous reste un
peu d'argent mais non sérieusement je
commence à m'inquiéter moi voyez dès que
je donne une somme j'ai un client plus
vous voyez dans l'âme il faut donner
pour recevoir
tu vas recevoir mon nom est tu vas
recevoir bien alors moon aliou bah oui
vous êtes riche donc on va vous faire
une interview à si j'étais pauvre
[Musique]
alors mona si vous étiez pour est ce que
vous auriez une montre comme ça d'abord
magnifique votre monde a fait voir
d'ailleurs caché là c'est maintenant
jean puis ça va énerver a relaté olivier
franchement y'en a pour elle une
problème tout se passait bien jusqu'à
vous rendez compte
je vais acheter l'extrême-gauche trois
ans de salaire ça n'entre en tant
qu'héritier du rheu ça vaut quoi trois
ans de salaire 4 ans de salaire non
versé 6900 ça dépend des prix en europe
et le bas
tu veux l'hiver que l'été l'été bien
donc si vous étiez pour vous auriez
demande comme ça quand même
vous voulez une vous économisez ongs et
pendant dix ans pour acheter une montre
comme ça mona il me faut bien sûr savoir
le temps on est de lui laurent je crois
que tu sais laurent fait ça très bien
qu'on ait eu le plaisir d'être dans le
métro pendant des années ses saveurs ses
sabres j'avais peur ce soit trop vous
n'avez ou psy vous étiez pauvres vous
joueriez de quels instruments de musique
dans le métro
dionne l'on a comme deviers joncour vous
porteriez quel vêtement si vous étiez
pauvres ce que j'aime parce
qu'aujourd'hui on dirait un pull noir
qu'est ce qui vous manquerait le plus
mouna si vous étiez pour l'amour en quoi
cela gênait l'amour
ça hyper bien merci voilà moon a
condamné aujourd'hui c'est incroyable
si vous étiez pauvres à qui empruntent
feriez vous de l'argent vous êtes avec
le crédit lyonnais madame ouais je suis
en retraite occupé du crédit lyonnais
oui sur des pagnes populaires je vous
propose parfois trop longtemps excusez
moi mais vous savez que henri de france
2 le fils du comte de paris est venu ici
nous a parlé de vous il était à la
banque avec le crédit lyonnais
il paraît qu'un jour il y en a interdit
de rentrer vous étiez piquet de grève
et vous lui avait interdit de rentrer je
me souviens pas de lui mais on essayait
d'empêcher effectivement les dirigeants
de rentrer dans l'entreprise quand on
était en grève
oui alors à qui on compte auriez-vous de
l'argent si vous étiez pauvre mouna aux
membres et aux membres de ma famille le
plus proche et le plus riche que moi
est-ce que vous soyez capable de vendre
de la drogue si vous étiez pauvres non
très très pauvre impossible impossible
impossible même des drogues douces est
facilement un peu pour un peu d'argent
jamais vous penseriez quoi des gens qui
vivent seuls dans 300 m² si vous étiez
pauvre bas d'abord j'irai essai de temps
de trouver du boulot chez eux mètre
carré cé carré chambre de bonne
oui est-ce que si vous étiez peau vous
voteriez pour l'extrême gauche
encore une fois ça dépend des objectifs
de l'extrême gauche 6 vous demander de
l'argent grosso modo quoique étude est
très très riche à un petit peu il y en a
qui bossent et qu'on pas d'argent alors
6 par la poste en tout cas à la fois
c'est un peu inutile par mois c'est
moins qu'à montre donc j'arrête de
déconner sinon j'ai pu voir de courrier
chez moi toi c'est sur une facture
quoique ça ça a du bon mais quelle heure
est il
non sérieusement samba ou pas voter
voter si samba la table les gens disent
que ça me va très bien
vous feriez pour l'extrême gauche si
vous êtes cpo encore une fois je lis ça
dépend des objectifs que l'extrême
gauche et des candidats lors l'objectif
ça serait que vous ne soyez moins
pauvres finalement ça ça lors du crime
et si en utilisant l'argent des riches
non à vous être contre l'idée qu'on
prenne aux riches pour donner aux
pauvres tout à fait que je suis
attentionné envers ce ne serait ce pour
elle a bien sûr trouver un emploi pour
tout le monde et que les salaires soient
justes
ouais mais je suis plutôt pour le
travail mois mais l'idée qui des gens
par exemple yens 600 aussi sont pour le
travail
j'aimerais bien trouver mais l'idée muna
à l'idée qui est des gens qui l'aiment
600 mille francs par mois et d'autres
6000 francs est ce que ça vous choque ou
non ça ne choque pas pas du tout mais
pourtant attendait excusez moi tout une
ânesse chrétienne en tant que chrétienne
c'est choquant ça non qui des gens qui
gagnent 6000 francs et doute 600000 non
encore une fois ça dépend de leur
capacité de ce qu'il faut autour ne peut
pas faire le même boulot il ya des gens
qui peuvent assumer une responsabilité
importante le pays a besoin de tous ces
gens là on pouvait pas payer tous ces
gens là même salaire le petit
travailleur tranquille que je suis comme
dirait ma fille créé travaux qui a
hérité
voilà je sais que en travaillant dur
très dur on gagne beaucoup moins une
fois de plus 6000 francs par mois que
certaines personnes que je croise à
neuilly quand foutent pas une et qui
gagnent beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez la preuve qui ne
foutent rien il ya des spéculateurs à la
bourse vous savez c'est leur seul métier
qui place parce qu'une entreprise qui
ferme
et puisque même en faisant des bénéfices
il place hilares achète et puis l'art
font couler après et puis la main qui
vivent que de ça vous savez ça existait
une toute petite minorité de la
population je dis pas que c'est votre
cas mais ça existe mais ces gens-là ils
travaillent pas ils travaillent vraiment
pas eu ces les vrais parasites y en a qu
à vibes et retraités les chômeurs et les
salariés c'est ça que je comprends pas
ce que je sais ça pourquoi tu dis
pourquoi tu dis démago parce que depuis
tout à l'heure je j'entends des choses
qui me font hurler voix et je voulais
simplement lui dire une fois pour toutes
vous êtes un démagogue
pourquoi pourquoi parce que parce que
globalement à chaque fois monsieur
besancenot pour expliquer sa politique
prend et prend des exemples sur des
petites exceptions dans la société
il en fait des généralités il essaie par
ce fait de monter les gens contre je ne
sais pas je ne sais quel patronat quel
capitalisme est globalement bon ben ça
vaut rien sourit double mai
moment discours il ya effectivement une
toute petite partie de la population
dont je parle mais c'est une infime
partie peut-être 1%
ça c'est pas mes chiffres à moi c'est
pas les chiffres je vais terminer juste
si tu peux attendre n'est pas c'est mon
choix donc je vais c'est terminé
d'accord attentats temps mais c'est
terminé je fais c'est terminé je te dis
1% de la population qui possède plus de
50 % des richesses de ce pays
et moi mon discours c'est à dire qu'il
ya deux millions et demi de chômeurs il
ya 5 millions de pauvres et il ya neuf
millions de personnes aujourd'hui qui
vivent avec moins de 5000 francs par
mois si juste ça que ça sera votre
dernier mot monsieur je voulais juste
demandé à monsieur dassault une chose
est ce qu'il existe des patrons qui ne
sont pas des salles aux dépens des
[ __ ] des [ __ ] des patrons se
revend qui a des patrons qui font
généreux qui font tout ce que tu voudras
moi je te parle du patronat comme
collectif comme une un groupe social qui
existe
oui ou non dans la soie 6,7 contre le
patronat oui le medef par exemple
souleymane gros sons sont ne sont pas
fréquentables ça c'est non mais si si si
le but du jeu c'est d'essayer de me
faire dire merci ainsi que je veux
prendre tous les patrons c'est pas mon
discours bien par contre le patronat
comme groupe collectif
le medef il un projet de société pour
moi mais aussi pour toi mais je trouve
ça très bien qu'on va le public puisse
participation c'est normal ça s'appelle
tout le monde en parle bien alors si on
change
alors dernière question moon a pour qui
vous voteriez en fait vous deviez voter
pour l'extrême gauche pourra l'être
laguiller ou pour olivier besancenot
ils sont ensemble je n'ai pas ou
présentant son présidentielle quand même
obs a attendu on ne s'est pas cassé
d'ici là
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous
m
très bien merci demande comment vous les
trouvez alors arlette laguiller et
olivier besoin j'ai oublié va si vite
alors ils vont parvenir parce qu'on a
maintenant des cartes de bons clients
qu'on donne aux gens qui sont agréables
quand même bien comme ça ils reviennent
avec leur carte quand ils veulent même
quand ils n'ont pas de promo quoi
comment vous les trouvez alors très
sympathique
il y connaît beaucoup de choses que je
connais pas c'est une icône et les
journaux le matin pour distribuer le
courrier de s'écouter n'avait jamais
fait alors soit vous êtes chez vous
imaginer à l'époque vous habitiez à
neuilly d'état neuilly le matin et
l'italie lui voyez arriver olivier
besancenot avec le courrier cassou lui
fait ni mon jour c'est tout prenez un
café avec moi a fait un petit cadeau
quand même l ai dit tu as vu leur
un petit cadeau pour les bonnes oeuvres
de la pause ils sont partis je vais lui
envoyer par email n'aura pas assis ici
et maintenant
[Musique]
oui si fabien galthié
oui
[Musique]
rabia guerre civile m messieurs alors
fabien galthié bains 1 m 80 j ça pour
vous mener à un mètre 81 82 kg madame ex
capitaine de l'équipe de france de rugby
nommé meilleur joueur du monde par lee
ermey en 2002 champion de france cette
année avec le stade français 2 me de
mêler le plus capé c'est bien qu'ils
aient eu le plus de sélections en équipe
de france laurent le plus capé
s'applaudit mesdames messieurs
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il est très
séduisant à ce qu'elle tient non vous
trouvez pas moules à 8000 euros
alors j'ai mis ça avant vous
[Musique]
tragédie chante les bee gees parce que
c'est pas la joie
vous rentrez d'australie le mondial de
rugby s'était achevée le 20 novembre par
une défaite des français face aux
all-blacks 13 40
la pâte est dans le match pour la
troisième place qu'on appelle la finale
des battus donc la france est quatrième
et loupe le podium d'une marche
alors expliquez vous non mais je pense
que il faut surtout enfin la défaite
c'est surtout la défaite en demi-finale
qu'ils aient été difficile à vivre parce
que bon la petite finale c'est une autre
histoire mais ce n'est pas la note il ya
ensuite ils ont fait jouer que des
remplaçants non je crois je crois pas
qu'il faut faire un qui fasse faire un
procès au jour qui jouer la petite
finale c'est déjà je dirais c'est
différent parce que lorsqu'on se prépare
à tout
durant quatre mois pour une grande
compétition et qu'on a la mission être
champion du monde
lorsque vous perdez à la demie celle en
demi-finale de la compétition et parce
qu'on va terminer c'est vrai que le
petit chien est un match important mais
mais voilà c'est comme ça la défaite son
parti du jeu enfin quand même des cinq
grandes nations du rugby international
une seule n'a pas encore été championne
du monde c'est la france quand même ça
va venir
c'est bien il reste des choses même le
cameroun a gagné vous pensez que ça peut
arriver quand même moi je pense que bon
cette année on a perdu en demi finale il
ya quatre ans on a perdu en finale face
à l'australie et à temps il ya huit ans
on avait perdu en demi finale face au
sud africaine à une baignade messieurs
passé pas loin
on n'est pas très loin et on n'est pas
donc je crois que bill reste peut-être
dans quatre ans la coupe du monde aura
lieu en france et peut-être l'équipe du
moment son championnat
las il s'est pas dans quatre ans en tête
dans huit c'est tous les quatre ou dans
12 ans
voir benaize ça va venir c'est là quand
ça se passe en france que la gagne et
quand même faut la gagner c'est vrai
mais le sport le sport c'est cet
instinct jeu on n'est pas sûr de gagner
à tous les coups et avons non
l'investissement fait bien commencer par
académie et culture organise ses
différents quoi vous n'auriez pas aimé
rester jusqu'en 2007 un an mais moi je
suis j'ai 34 ans je joue depuis un long
moment et je crois que je suis arrivé je
suis arrivé au bout du chemin comme bien
des cas c'est si aulas la cimade ça la
révision des 5e 6e cas ces éléments ne
se renseignent et elle regarde un peu
comme ces derniers n'ont que peu d'échos
ki moon a rejeté un peu mais ce que
parfois qu'ils sont devenus
c'est protéger protéger pas autant que
le sport américain
non mais l'américaine photo n'est pas on
n'est pas tes d'abord de gênant
justement venir se protège pas trop
longues ou là c'est pour ça qu'il ya
beaucoup de cas soit il ya enfin des
traumatismes mais bon on est préparé
pour ça aussi donc non mais dans
l'ensemble ça va ça vient plus des
mauvais coups dans les parties non non
non non ça va pour le moment savoir si
c'est vrai il ya des attouchements dans
l'est mais laissez moi c'est une des
parties qui a pas été encore touché bon
des attouchements ça peut arriver aux
salariés par année mais les vestiaires
ouais ou dans les soirées fait un peu
partout alors la fédération va
reconduire la porte le 13 décembre vous
pensez je sais pas reconduire à la porte
rené nan sérieux je ne sais pas c'est ça
c'est un choix qui est qui incombe au
président son bureau mais je pense que
bernard les compétents a fait ce qu'ils
pouvaient pour avoir la meilleure équipe
possible
mais il ya aussi d'autres d'autres
d'autres candidats c'est certain mais
on n'a pas donné les joueurs on n'a pas
tellement dans hilton n'a pas tellement
à s'exprimer à ce sujet vous aurez plus
de le remplacer
non pas de suite là je prends un peu de
recul de suite dit non c'est vrai que je
pense que je reviendrai au terrain
france comme entraîneur soit comment
peut- être manager je n'en sais rien
parce que comme toi on joue depuis l'âge
de 7 ans et quoi quand on a cette
passion du ballon rond ben on peut
paraître on y parle non létaux vol suis
bien c'est vrai que j'ai la chance là
c'est la montre parce qu'il repasse à la
montre tous tes mots s'interrompt je
voulais le montrer de quelle montre me
parles tu es notre vie ma montre
ce n'est pas le monde mais dites-moi
sérieusement il faudra quand même
constituer une équipe pour 2007 qui soit
capable de jouer quand il pleut parce
qu'il paraît que vous avez perdu la
demi-finale parce qu'il pleuvait du
camembert dans ça c'est vrai non mais
c'est d'abord on a perdu c'est vrai que
les conditions climatiques n'étaient pas
on n'a pas une équipe
par vous pensez que ces villages où vous
jouez avec une capuche qu'ils avaient
des chances de gagner ou le terrain
couvert
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a une équipe
qui est qui qui manque qui manque aux
femmes on en parle entre dans la
stratégie dans le jeu mais sinon
attendez moi on me dit ils ont perdu la
demi finale contre les anglais parce
qu'il pleuvait tout c'est un truc qui
arrive quand même la pluie
malheureusement une mauvaise météo c'est
tout le monde alors là encore vous
cherchez vous pêchez je pêche un péché
par excès alors comment on peut perdre
parce que l'ère des mulliez le terrain
est gras à partie moment où il pleut
le ballon à une grippe il est difficile
d'attraper le ballon ça glisse est tout
à fait ce que je ne suis pas trop
technique et pour moi savoir qu'est ce
que les anglais non non c'est une anti
glisse c'est à dire que quand le père le
ballon glissant il faut jouer
différemment il faut jouer à jouer la
coupe est pleine il jouait très près les
uns des autres et en limitant le nombre
de passes parce que chaque à chaque pas
sans risque de tomber le ballon
nous on a un jeu fin les français on est
moins puissant que que l'écho les anglo
saxons on a un jeu qui est plus plus
dynamique plus plus basé sur la vitesse
et sur la vitesse d'exécution et c'est
vrai que pour faire des passes de langue
pas assez rapide lorsque le ballon
glissant ça devient très compliqué parce
qu'un possible et donc il faut changer
de stratégie il faut jouer plus près du
jeu à une passe
c'est ce qu'on appelle du défi et à ce
jeu là on est en manque de puissance
solaire évolue de 10 quand il pleut fo -
de passe
je prends beaucoup de plaisir à notre
avis bien sûr bien sûr qu'en général les
rugbymans il pose nu d'habitude
non
tu te demandais ce que tu allais faire
dans la vie maintenant voilà on dirait
un album pour enfants une comptine muna
et fabien aventures de mon iphone fabien
il a dit combien il le dit dans le rugby
j'ai atteint mes limites et ça y est
vous en avez assez là ouais ouais ouais
je crois que j'ai fait tout ce que je
pouvais faire enfin j'ai pas de regret
quand je suis allé au bout de ce que je
pouvais faire bon j'ai pas été champion
du monde mais c'est pas faute d'avoir
essayé pour un essai c'est vrai voilà
vous avez pu jouer au rugby heures non
je vous prie non ce plan est voté il
faut savoir tourner la page parce que
c'est vrai que c'est jamais évident
quand on a passé toute sa vie à
s'entraîner régulièrement fait le récit
des sensations que je connaîtrai plus et
ce matin je suis allé voir mes camarades
du stade français qui préparer leur
dernier entraînement pour jouer demain
et c'est vrai que ça m'a fait quelque
chose donc il vaut mieux tourner la page
radicalement plutôt que savez dans le
sport de haut niveau il faut savoir
s'arrêter au bon moment parce que si
vous faites l'année de trop vous et
préparez bien sûr votre reconversion
faisait naître chez singer c'est canal +
1 1
la mairie de paris ouais voilà mais
désormais bon votre vie va être assez
vite quand même non mais non là je vais
déjà je m'en vais je commente un match
ce week-end pour canal donc c'est une
façon de rester assez proche de mon
sport et sans avoir aucune pression
essayer de continuer à vivre ma passion
l'émotion et puis essayer de faire
partager avec le plus grand nombre et
puis je crois que la ville de paris a de
grands projets notamment la coupe doit
organiser la coupe du monde 2007
les candidates aux jeux olympiques 2012
et ça c'est déjà fantastique a à faire
je pense que il ya de quoi faire alors
vous avez vous avez déclaré que le rugby
pro finalement maintenant cela fait
quand même beaucoup changé le rugby est
ce que c'est une des raisons de votre
arrêt comme ça de non au contraire je
crois que j'ai joué plus longtemps que
prévu parce que moi j'ai connu le rugby
on s'entraînait d'autres fois par
semaine
ouais et puis à partir de 95 on
s'entraîne tous les jours puis a pris
deux fois par jour puis après on a mis
des préparateurs physiques en place on a
mis une toute une stratégie de
préparation ce qui m'a permis de
continuer à maintenir un certain niveau
c'est beaucoup de boulot parce qu'avant
il y avait dix plaquage c'est vrai
maintenant il ya des plaquages pour
jouer il y avait dit mi temps effectif
de jeu maintenant il ya quarante ans
après le match le plus difficile c'était
souvent l'apéro d'après match alors que
maintenant il ya plus à pratiquement
plus apéro parce que le lendemain à
l'entraînement mais on était très bon à
l'apéro commencé c'était très dur et
c'est que le rugby en se
professionnalisant est devenu moins
sympa non quand on descend je pense
qu'il ya toujours cette atmosphère les
valeurs du rugby c'est c'est la
convivialité c'est la fraternité c'est
le sait le don de soi ses engagements
c'est l'humilité il ya beaucoup de
valeur je trouve que c'est un beau sport
avec des valeurs des belles valeurs
mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau haut niveau
on peut moins de faire la fête au moins
faire les cons mais si vous descendez en
deuxième division ou en universitaire il
ya toujours cet esprit on chante
toujours des chansons après les matchs
sur l'apéro c'est toujours à poil même
sony commence juste justement on va
regarder quelques images du calendrier
[Musique]
paulo
étaient ils à quai
loblaw est mauvais et longwy
non
[Musique]
elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais
selon m
qu'on est là
aussi
je me plais
on voit ainsi que des bureaux à rouen
nec là
[Musique]
machaie
ac le making of du cadre
2004 les dieux du stade symbole
magnifique vraiment vous avez vu ça vous
les connaissiez les mecs du voulait que
je n'en ai encore saas et des perdants
fabius
tu as bien il va tout plaisant et très
bien ouais je fais faut venir à jean
bouin jours le samedi et vous verrez
tout le monde les femmes peuvent y aller
bien sûr elles sont elles sont très bien
accueillis dans des cocktails
ils seront pas nul hein légèrement vêtu
légèrement vêtues après c'est à vous de
faire un chèque ou de séduire on ne sait
mur vous êtes plutôt footballeur
houdmann bout moi je dis ça je suis
plutôt rugby même parce que j'adore le
football américain nous rien oui c'est
moche absolument c'est très proche sauf
que bien sûr le football américain
énormément de protection il me faut un
autre a dit non elle est dans un état
pareil ça vous a fait c'est très très
posé il y avait une mise en scène sur
les cévennes même moi qui suis hétéro ça
me après la chose c'est magique c'est
vraiment beau ça vous excite pas du tout
ça m'amuse
c'est amusant on a passé franchement
n'appartient brest également entre
copains
et c'est pourquoi nos crochets
calendrier d'un parent essai pour
commencer 2004 et on va faire fait ils
font mais quel mois quelle heure quinze
jours
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant armande altaï
comment avait dû monter bonsoir mon 5e
heureux de vous voir voilà longtemps que
j'ai rarement vu laurent mais que des
chausse pied
tout est calé un ouais c'est pas très
compliqué ça s'appelle la galanterie ce
tout petit c'est bien et c'est très bien
vraiment pardon tu es à tapas est égal
avec moi tu veux qu'on parle de la loge
pas dit mercier est ce qu'ils vont
connaissez les le calendrier des du
stade français moi oui non si vous aimez
les beaux hommes très bien très bien
fait très bien pensé non pas votre truc
non non je lorsque chaque fois que j'ai
été séduit par un acteur c'était pas un
athlète c'était quelque chose de
mystérieux qui se passait là vous êtes
cérébrale plutôt vouloir mordre je ne
sais pas peut-être fait un bel animal
aussi très belle à l'image de blessure
pourquoi arrivée vous parce que c'est un
sportif parce qu'on est il comprend pas
ce qu'on dit il est régulier main
je trouve qu'il avait qu'avec son est
tout plat comme ça dans l'alignement du
franc il a un profil à la cocteau
méfie toi et c'est vrai football comme
c'est vrai il ya bien de voter jean marc
ela bien alors morale target la prof de
chant de la star ac on ne vous présente
plus vous étiez sur plateau de la star
ac et encore une dizaine de minutes vous
êtes là maintenant magie de la
télévision et rapidité des taxis
parisiens
comment venir de ce château jusqu'ici
c'est absolument incroyable
vous faisiez vous êtes venu parce que
vous étiez la main sur le plateau la saq
non non sérieux j'avais terriblement
envie de vous voir c'est gentil ça fait
une taille de merde ouais oui elle me
l'a dit juste avant oui en tout cas on
est ravis on va parler du livre art
montre que vous publiez vie vous vous
raconter votre vie mais auparavant
quelques mails de téléspectateurs qui
savait que vous veniez ce soir frédéric
sicot de bollène dans le vaucluse
armande est ce que vous faites prof de
chant à la star ac pour l'argent ou pour
le plaisir et l'honneur de découvrir des
talents comme jean pascal
pour les deux maintenant pour les deux
c'était une aventure maintenant c'est
pour les deux alors tania roeg de
strasbourg pourquoi la star ac vous dit
pas tout de suite qui va gagner
et parce que c'est on ne le sait pas ah
bon c'est les gens qui votent et
l'intérêt c'est que ce soit le plus
grand nombre de gens qui votent qui se
sont ceux qui vont acheter donc - 13 %
des gens n'y croient pas oui mais ça
c'est parce que c'est truqué
je crois que tant quelque chose de
truquer la télé ça se sait très vite il
a vomi des jeux des jeux intervilles ou
un truc comme ça je pense que maintenant
plus personne prendrait le risque
dominique gaz tout de nîmes vous trouvez
pas qu oscar le prof de théâtre il joue
un peu comme une saucisse cd m les
téléspectateurs non non ce car moi je
les vis dans un spectacle magnifique
daria ce qui serait morte à des là il
était très bien lancé bernard livia ni
de chamonix armande c'est vrai que nikos
aliagas rock john lennon va venir la
semaine prochaine
non bien bruno d'heure de paris a oui ça
c'est plus grave
armand on est ce que votre coiffure
c'est suite à un pari ah là là s'il
m'avait vu il ya quelques années
bon françois alors lui je ne sais pas
comment il s'appelle françois sovilla de
cherbourg j'ai retrouvé les chansons que
vous chantiez dans les années 80 est ce
que vous prenez des trucs à l'époque
non pas trop
oui
m
[Musique]
stop ou encore ça ressemble à klaus nomi
un peu
c'était important
m
je vais vous dire moi
moi je vais bien encore une fois je
demande dans cette émission qu'on passe
les 10 que la vitesse normale alors
armande vous publié chez jean claude
lattès votre autobiographie qui
s'appelle cette musique qui me vient de
loin et effectivement on voit en lisant
ça que vous avez une vie beaucoup plus
drôle que les gens d'astarac j'ai une
vie incroyable d'une richesse absolument
extraordinaire on y va vous êtes né en
mai 44 alep en syrie
espèce de forteresse médiévale voilà
ouais pas loin de chez vous un en syrie
alep
voilà votre père officier français votre
mer orientale
votre mère descendait d'un bep turc qui
descendait lui-même des sultans voilà et
comme christian vadim la semaine
dernière lui descendait de gengis camp
mais vous aussi vous descendez de gengis
khan par votre mère peut-être par an par
an avec les sens l'a10 main donc avec
catherine deneuve incroyable bien alors
votre mère vous transmet l'amour de la
musique ah oui c'est de la coiffure
également tort elle était très sobre
toujours toujours pendu à la rue
sérieusement c'est vrai ouais ma mère
écouter écouter radio le caire
ouais tous les soirs elle s'endormait
sur la voie doom donc atteint
oh
c'est pas où il était tout blanc alors
vous endormir en écoutant ça tous les
soirs non oui oui et pas seulement nous
en norme en longueur de journée on
écoute et cela alors le père était une
caricature de militaires c'était
vraiment le militaire type
vie au clairon élevage de la cravache un
peu non c'est vrai ouais c'était un
homme formidable en même temps parce
qu'il était il savait tout faire non il
joue au football et très bien il était
maître nageur il était maître
d'équitation les chevaux arrivés allure
au souffle il est dirigé à l'oreille des
chevaux
oui mais aussi wii façon il avait pris
ça chez les cosaques justement dans la
famille de ma grand-mère et l'hérésie
signer à l'as et ils étaient tous une
sorte de héros par l'extérieur mais très
très dur quand même
c'est en a tous des ombres en nous et il
ya des gens qui cultivent ces ombres
parce qu'elles servent dans l'armée en
cultive quelquefois les ombres ensuite
vous quittez donc le moyen-orient votre
famille part vivre en côte d'ivoire et
là vous avez une enfance comme ça de
petites negri johan admin oui c'est ça
c'est vrai 2000 lui avec aline qui
s'appelait coco donc c'est tout ça c'est
très bien de minots nos copeaux on voit
les images est tellement bien sur la
route de la mission comme c'est vrai
qu'à cette époque les baoulé n'était pas
habillé incendié à l'époque qu'ils
avaient des colliers et très souvent nue
donc nous on vous aussi voilà et alors
ce coco ce qu'on commet là c'est très
grave ce coco d'or devant la chambre des
enfants et en fait on comprend à demi
mot d'ailleurs en lisant votre livre qui
protéger les enfants et surtout votre
soeur contre les assauts de votre père
est ce que je me suis trompé ou pas en
lisant le bouquin non c'est un petit peu
comme ça est ce que il ya eu des choses
avec votre soeur nilda à l'époque c'est
ce que je dis dans le livre
en tout cas ce qu'on lit dans le livre
c'est que votre soeur a été éloigné et
qui aura plus jamais de cohabitation
avec votre père voilà alors l'été 49
vous arrivez à marseille où vous dites
que vous fabriquez vos racines
votre père lui a way bunker
votre père lui par en indochine et vous
avez de moins en moins de deux nouvelles
de lui vous êtes là avec votre mère et
les enfants
il disparaît complètement donc
évidemment vous êtes mise à l'école
publique parce qu'il ya plus de blé et
puis ça devient dur la vie quoi
l'épicier refuse de vous servir et tout
ça quoi c'est ryanair là mais c'est j'en
ai pas souvenir trop tragique parce que
notre mère avait choisi de ne plus
d'argent qu'elle avait c'était pour la
musique les disques le cinéma alors ça a
choqué beaucoup nos petites copines
parce que elle n'allait jamais au cinéma
mais vous avez les petits jupon en nylon
à la mode
les petites chaînes en or et nous on
faisait comme notre mère on sait ans se
promener comme si on était en robe de
bal même si on avait des choses très
très vieille sur le dos et mais par
contre avoir raconté les films qu'on
joué chez nous on était très acteurs
très très danseurs et chanteurs la bande
des frères et soeurs et les petites
camarades nous suivait alors on faisait
exprès de pas dire la fin tout de suite
vous allez coquette elle nous suivait
pour savoir la fin de l'histoire et non
les plaignants du mais vous n'allez
jamais au cinéma au pauvre petite heure
d'été très s'est lancé comme ça que vous
découvrez mahalia jackson qui était
évidemment très importante pour vous
dans votre carrière de chanteuse plus
tard alors voilà ces devises passe à
marseille quand vous avez dix ans un
jour votre père vers les mecs sont
gonflés je n'aurais jamais osé faire ça
le mec qui se barre et il revient au
lieu dit de la fermer et de s'écraser
il revient avec deux vietnamienne pas
une 2 oui non mais c'est incroyable
quand même si c'est un culot absolument
phénoménale non pourquoi pour mettre ça
dans la bibliothèque
non mais c'est vrai et trois enfants oui
quel culot quand même n'en veulent
sérieusement
entre temps on a appris qu'il y en avait
d'autres ouais on a eu des nouvelles
d'autres personnes
parent choisir c'est que les
vietnamiennes sont toujours disponibles
ah bon vous allez être la mienne aussi
mena mais oui ah bon non mais c'est
incroyable personnellement ses amis
presque
je ne sais pas ce qui leur a dit pour
pour qu elle l a eu l'air surpris aussi
de trouver une famille catteau elle
aussi oui alors votre maire tente de
s'empoisonner à ce moment là oui avec
des baguettes et là et le père disparaît
presque aussitôt
et là où il est encore plus boucler ça
il réapparaît quelques années plus tard
il vient chercher l'argent pour vanter
un resto avec les deux vietnamiens un
restaurant chinois et et vous êtes
obligé de vendre l'appartement où vous
habitez et vous installer dans un
quartier très excentré voilà cc c'est
fou quand on voit ça non en plus nous
étions des étrangères parce que ma mère
était turc
eris mélanger nous nous étions des des
petites orientale aussi on a appris le
français doucement on avait des accents
donc on nous regardait de travers et dès
qu'on dise est notre père est militaire
tout de suite à nous recevait donc
quelque part c'était une position très
ambiguë parce que on était on était un
petit peu un pack un petit peu nous
étions ses victimes et en même temps la
salle ont rejoint le reconnaissez quand
même comme quelqu'un de heureusement qu'
à ce père est officier pour vous
rattraper la famille locale salaires
chinois
c'est incroyable et à 18 ans vous marier
avec un type un homme plus âgé que vous
qui vous a dit je t'aime voilà un geste
plus comme ça il a su trouver les mots
non mais c'est vrai dit exactement le
mot je t'aime et magique plus fort que
celui qui le dit oui on a tellement
besoin de l'entendre que lorsqu'on est
jeune et quelqu'un vous dit vous traite
d'une certaine manière vous regarde
donner l'impression d'exister et on se
trompe c'est le mot je t'aime qui est
plus fort que la personne qui les a été
touché par son regard vous dites oui
c'est je sais pas pourquoi j'aime les
hommes brun au regard triste et toujours
mais cette fois j'ai de la diva trash ça
c'est un bon gars ont valu un essai la
bagarre risque il un regard malicieux
non mais dit les mots magiques les
mauvais je t'aime
si désolée fabien il de fabien voir mais
c'est vrai il était dans l' angle là il
a reçu aussi il est beau tout va bien
c'est magnifique dis moi je te lance
plus je te trouve sympa ah c'est bien
bien et alors donc vous vous mariez
évidemment le lendemain matin 27 ans et
philippe absolue vous vous réveillez
dans une chambre est misérable chambre à
l'époque j'en passe faut traduire
chambrette c'est un endroit très petit
trait pour une petite chambre c'est une
petite chance dans les rangs des toits
sauf que mouna moi je vous connais
suffisamment pour savoir que quand vous
êtes arrivé à paris elles étaient les
deux bombes ont été serveuse diamant
elle avait une mini chambrette c'est
lagardère et c'est là qu'un soir dans un
restaurant
elle a vu arriver le saoudien avec la
blonde way est une chaîne appris la
venue semblables je crois qu'on peut le
dire bon ils sont coincés blanc l'un
parce que elle aurait pu rester
bien doit vous vous réveillez dans une
chambre elle a bon et puis
courageusement vous dites faut y aller
quand vous montez à paris avec votre
mari chez son frère à lui votre beau
frère tu vraiment un mauvais chiens mais
un connard j'ai jamais vu ça
j'avais envie de lui dire là je suis sûr
qu'il me regarde non mais c'était non
mais c'était déjà mieux 40 de notre
époque de ma génération
c'étaient des hommes normaux à l'époque
c'était ça les mecs
voilà en fait mannequin parce que vous
avez une tête un chignon quoi c'était la
mode des voilà un chignon pompadour de
68 à l'époque je faisais dans une grande
famille maintenant c'est différent vous
êtes mannequin à ce moment là
effectivement vous commencez à faire un
petit peu pour la coiffure pour la mode
tout ça vous commencez un petit peu a
fréquenté le tout-paris armande et votre
mari ça c'est terrible pour vous garder
à la maison il vous met enceinte
oui c'est aussi quelque chose qui se
faisait avant c'était pas extraordinaire
non mais là quelque part il a bien fait
et vous un jour c'est dans un jardin
public
et là vous accouchez non j'ai pas lu le
livre
non je paye temps je suis ensuite
d'étagés le bouquet devrait lui je
glande ans par an dont la riche parce
que tu fais pas le temps mais c'est lui
nuitées jours
il est là il faut rien je sais pas alors
donc je vois une petite fille avec un
petit garçon qui lui prend un objet joie
la petite fille qui bouge et ça me tord
le coeur mais c'est terrible j'ai un
espèce de choc
je sais pas à quoi c'est dû je me
l'expliqué toujours pas et j'ai compris
que ce serait mon enfant serait comme ça
j'ai eu la même voilà j'ai reconnu alors
que j'étais au début de ma grossesse
j'ai reconnu l'enfant que j'allais avoir
c'était une petite fille comme sam
brunette et j'ai dit c'est la mienne
bon d'accord elle préfigure l enfant
voit laquelle eric en virginie est
arrivé c'était exactement voilà celle là
celle là la même c'est incroyable cette
histoire j'en suis écoute
voilà alors ensuite fait des petits
boulots dj vais vous chanter des
chansons dans les restos quand vous
retournez dans le sud de la france
chantait à cassis vous faites un
concours de talent local destiné à
trouver des candidats pour le jeu de la
chance il est extraordinaire dans toute
cette histoire c'est qu'armand vous avez
fait le jeu de la chance c'est à dire
que finalement vous avez fait la star ac
de l'époque kouassi et je n'ai pas fait
en définitive
j'aimerais passer on va vous deviez j'ai
créé le concours des voix là c'est le
jeu qui a permis de découvrir à mireille
mathieu thierry le luron
mais en fait vous le faites pas vous y
renoncer oui pourquoi
et parce que j'étais déjà j'avais déjà
un vieux août stoxx a eu plein de choses
et j'ai compris tu es pas la musique que
je voulais faire venir comme georgette
lemaire
je ne savais pas s'il y avait une
ouverture pour le genre musique je
faisais qui était complètement étrange
bouffe
vous mentez à paris en abandonnant votre
marié votre enfant non je les abandonne
pas je les ai jamais aimé de lui avant
mais c'est ce que tu en sais rien le
mari et le mari je comprends mais
l'enfant mais oui je pensais revenir
plus souvent où la voix souvent ou qui
me l'amènerait c'est vrai mais je n'ai
jamais abandonné j'ai toujours travaillé
et envoyer de l'argent et me suis
toujours occupé d'elle je dressais comme
une année sans l'avoir virginie il ya eu
presque deux ans ou gelée pratiquement
pas vu parce qu'ils amenaient pas parce
que les choses ne se faisait pas et donc
j'ai je suis quasiment aller l'enlever
ouais avec l'aide d'une avocate
alors voilà donc à paris c'est un petit
peu la galère vous êtes à l'échelle de
jacob mais vous êtes vestiaires et vous
êtes violée par la violer
déjà comme c'est l'échelle de richter au
litige on ne saute dessus et m'ont ne
viole pas je ne serais pas laisser faire
c'est que je sais qui c'est orlando est
dit non c'est un auteur que vous
admiriez beaucoup oui et un jour il vous
sautent dessus j'ai rendez vous avec lui
oui la rage au vêtement enfin c'est
vraiment bestial comme comme histoire
vous arrivez à vous enfuir
on ne sait pas comment un auteur de coup
un dramaturge un auteur de chansons à
deux chansons que je rigole il avait
échoué non non non ne vous dit pas le
nom dans le livre
rien n'a pas 50 1 avec des yeux de
batraciens vous dit ça en tout cas
oui c'est son regard caché là regard de
batraciens et que vous le croisez encore
de detroit pétillant puis après à ce
moment là comme tous les hommes qui nous
permet aujourd'hui à fait d'accord je
vous dire que moi je dirai après enfin
je pouvais voter celle qui ne dit mot
consent je repère bon je dis ni nom ni
oui parce que ça peu après ça on procède
par élimination un peu ça je répondrai
pas en demande cela que je le sais
je n'ai rien dit ni oui ni non parce
qu'elles sont morts et on rêve on va
procéder par élimination
d'accord il a trouvé et c'est pas le
même 1 ce qui assez sa as bravo non non
non non non lésés par le dit pas c'est
ça c'est ça
il a trouvé passant au-dessus 67k
voilà donc peut envoyer les noms sur le
site france2 le gagnant aura une soirée
entière à dakar monde altaï voilà c'est
la moindre des choses
donc ça c'est l'époque montmartre à ce
moment là vous faites la manche un petit
peu dans les restos en chantant et
jouant de la guitare et là vous tombez
sur un mec extraordinaire qui est
milliardaire alors vous découvrez un
jour d'ailleurs qu'il a une femme et des
enfants
mais la nuit vient rodellar il aime
passer ses nuits avec vous ce n'était
pas le même la journée c'était quelqu'un
que je ne connaissais pas c'est ça et
pendant très longtemps de ses vues que
la nuit voilà
or la nuit on se parlait presque pas en
je suis chaud thé seulement on se
comprenait à demi mot il y avait une
espèce de il était on était sous tous
les deux qu'on était jamais élucidé on
se voyait jamais le juge d'ailleurs donc
une autre personnalité
un autre personnage ouais alors il veut
vous installez il veut produire vos
disques et un soleil m'intéresse plus
vous refuse évidemment autres ensuite
s'est engagé dans le gospel ou fait la
rencontre de daniel auteuil de dave et à
ce moment-là armande vous retrouvez le
milliardaire qui revient et on l'a il
veut vous offrir à une star de la
chanson que vous appelez dans les
mystères mister c'est là que ce milliard
baird cd connu avant il vous présente à
ce mystère mystère qui est très amoureux
de vous or il le dit mais c'est pas ça
il pleure mais on vous embrasse et oui
mais à l'air sir autre chose
ouais tous les cas vous êtes très ému
par lui quand même un oui parce que j'ai
senti que
tout d'un coup c'était il y avait
quelque chose de grave qui m'échappe et
que je ne comprenais pas et il y avait
une sorte de petite voix intérieure qui
me disait sauve toi reste pas la cour
est ce que c'est parce que la même chose
alors si une énorme star ce type à rbo
l'appeler mystère mystère
c'est une énorme star tout le monde l'a
reconnu évidemment non
je vais vous dire je suis désolé on ne
peut pas le dire sinon on a des procès
après on s'attendrait pas
une énorme star très malheureuse énorme
ça la chanson française on n'est plus là
qui nous a quittés trop tôt mais c'est
lui
non elle ne dit pas qui c'est mais elle
me dit qu'il sait pas y arriveraient
toute façon bien voilà bon donc voilà
donc vous ne cédez pas à vous partez
sans faire l'amour avec lui je ne sais
pas une fille facile voire mandat il
encore
il ya trouvé de la grèce
on sort ce matin
voilà enfin là encore mieux vous l'avez
compris c'est un livre il a trouvé
presque que le prénom viendra ah non
c'est un prénom il y en a plusieurs
ouais bien donc voilà donc j'arrête
maintenant le livre est très très
intéressant c'est une vie incroyable non
quel bilan vous tiré de cette vie
aujourd'hui là ça c'était avant la star
ac' encore un abri à toutes la star ac
mais ça va je suis contente de moi j'ai
traversé une petite tempête suis entêtée
dans certaines choses d'ailleurs c'est
je dis souvent que mes défauts et mes
qualités sont les mêmes c'est
l'entêtement et l'orgueil c'est c'est
des défauts et des qualités aussi voilà
dites moi alors la semaine dernière là
tout le monde était passionné par le
conseil de discipline pour pierre est ce
que vous pensez qu'il va faire la
tournée d'été plus la france entière se
demande
je ne sais pas si la fra moi je trouve
que c'est c'est eh il est jeune il est
sorti avec un beau coup de panache et
c'est artistiquement c'était très bon
simplement quand quand on a des
responsabilités artistique il faut faire
attention à ne pas laisser ses petits
camarades en cours de route
c'est comme si lui quitté le match au
milieu c'est ce qu'il a fait que c'est
ce qu'il a fait d'ailleurs il est parti
avant le dernier match bien une chose
que je dis pas c'est que dans votre
bouquin armande vous parlez de moi mais
là j'aurai la discrétion évidemment le
pas mais c'est vrai parce qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose ailleurs
elle dit des trucs sympas sur moi ce
discours du palace tout ça c'est très
sympa il s'est passé quelque chose
à une époque où vous étiez un des
personnages de cette époque c'est à dire
que tous les coups la nuit a changé il
n'y a plus il n'y avait plus les friqués
entre qui revenait de saint-tropez dans
des petites boîtes
tout d'un coup il y avait plein plein de
gens de tous les milieux sociaux qui se
rencontrent et il y avait des des gens
de banlieue qui croisaient les sex
pistols ou des gens high tech ou
c'est incroyable fabrice merdes qui a
lancé tout
j'appelle ça les nuits mais disais voilà
voilà et vous étiez là et vous avez créé
ces nouvelles tokyo comme ça un peu
people est un peu branché un peu rock
je suis dans le vide un vent de douala
[Musique]
ces gens tous deux
oui
[Musique]
alors laurent me demande monsieur hamida
montre que qu'est ce que c'est que ces
sondages avaient déposé dans la loge de
mouna peut-être la demie
je marchais avec l'échangé ça va trouver
de là je reviens à tapas buts à rien ce
soir devant la datura 3 mondial fort sur
mer c'est justement série moi j'ai
approché des chaises je termine à non
j'étais c'est pourquoi je congèle ici ça
va merci bien pour elle il ya deux
périodes et combien sur le yacht a
semble-t-il fait beaucoup plus chaud je
tournais merci il ya des mecs là c'est
très bien mais tient à turant la montre
oui c'est bien non c'est bien laurent
lapeyre sur toi ça sera mieux ensemble
ouais tu viendras une belle montre un
beau yacht on s'y fait très fait si j'ai
eu le temps de changer les voyant j'ai
lu la pacotille mais tu vois que ça et
maintenant non non non non non non non
non non non non temps morts est
maintenant de temps mort enfin temps
mort attend c'est bon qu'il ressent
qu'on appelle une choucroute ça va tous
les goûts
tickets pas connu ça les règles du jeu
rugueux de quoi
oui enlève ton avion sans être en avance
oui pardon moon arrivé sur le plateau
les scouts et marie
mais sa ferme les yeux et maintenant
[Musique]
et
voici mathieu suisse
[Musique]
je suis mon soir bonsoir
do you hear me vous m'entendez avec une
bière et je vous entends cinq sur cinq
voilà aimait rire mais c'était en quoi
ça est neutre mais c'était encore tommy
tommy bravo des vous dominer ou à dix on
marque un point donc armande altaï qui
est prof de chant l'astarac matthew
énorme une star nationale en france elle
a fait trente ans de travail super belle
chanson elle se donne un mal de chien
est elle devenue star avec la star ac
voilà il raconte sa vie non non c'est
non pas trop facile quand on sait même
pas 30 ans quand même
alors je vous présente mouna ayoub et
fabien galthié
les mariés de l'an iii voilà voilà voilà
certain matthew
ça va mathieu savoie tout le pâté toi tu
pourras je comprends le stade bien ça va
oui ça va c'est vrai ça va ça va kiffer
la trad
c'est robert bon ça va reverser robert
j'ai d'abord ça va ça va ça va super
bien
serge savard catherine ça va très bien
dans tout le monde leur doit y aller
alors donc vous publiez matthew smith
chez plon un bouquin qui s'appelle
victimes
les dernières révélations de marilyn
monroe
oui parce qu'on croyait tout savoir et
on ne savait pas tout alors pour faire
simple la mort de marilyn ya plusieurs
thèses et la thèse du suicide
marilyn monroe s'est suicidé en
absorbant une dose massive de
barbituriques d'une un but a lancé la
version disant pratiquement officiel il
ya une autre thèse c'est qu'elle a été
poussé au suicide voire assassinés par
les frères kennedy
parce qu'après avoir été la maîtresse de
john et bob kennedy elle en savait trop
sur leurs liens avec la mafia est elle
menacée par les bref elle devenait
incontrôlable ça c'est les thèses
d'hydrocution discuté jusque là et votre
thèse matthew smith c'est encore une
autre thèse une troisième thèse en fait
les coupables sont des dissidents de la
cia qui ont été furieux de l'échec de la
tentative de débarquement anti castriste
à cuba dans la baie des cochons et qui
pour se venger aurait assassiné marilyn
monroe pour [ __ ] les kennedy dans la
mer pour se venger de cet échec et
ensuite il aurait d'ailleurs organisé
l'assassinât de john kennedy de son
frère bob et il aurait compromis edward
kennedy l'autre avec mary jo kopechne
est la fameuse affaire de chappaquiddick
quand eux ils tombent dans une rivière
avec mary jo kopechne et voilà alors
effectivement meurtre organisé
et par des dissidents de la cia pour se
venger de l'échec de la baie des cochons
c'est votre théorie pièce c'est ma
théorie oui à et une facture en fait je
vous avais présenté ça de manière
absolument brillante
je sais que la cia a été impliquée dans
cette affaire parce que l'année suivante
lors de l'assassinât de john f
j'ai un témoin oculaire quelqu'un qui
était un contact immédiat avec quelqu'un
qui a reconnu qu'il était membre de la
cia et qui a dit à mon indicateur la
veille de la ccja telle qu'ainsi qui lui
serait assassinée lorsqu'il viendrait à
dallas et c'est ce qui s'est passé et
puis il m'a dit que bob kennedy à son
team et trouverait la mort et c'est ce
qui s'est passé a ainsi alors quelque
chose qui se dégage on commence à avoir
une situation qui se répète c'était la
troisième tentative de se débarrasser
des canadiens jouent et dire que ce que
dit matthew smith
c'est finalement tout ça ne commence pas
avec l'assassinât de john fitzgerald
kennedy à dallas mais en fait ça
commence avec l'assassinât de marie line
en 62 par ces dissidents la cia ensuite
john fitzgerald kennedy ensuite bob
kennedy et ensuite l'histoire avec
edward kennedy dont katsav a dit cui
donc ce que vous dites en fait que c'est
une opération de plus de plus grande
ampleur et qui date depuis plus
longtemps que ce qu'on croyait en fait
sur hi media c'est exactement ça oui et
puis en plus ceux qui voulaient se
débarrasser de gfk était absolument
déterminés ils voulaient absolument s'en
débarrasser ils ont vu l'occasion de le
faire parce que bob kennedy à l'époque
fréquentes et maryline moment il était
chez elle deux fois la veille de sa mort
ils se sont disputés de manière
épouvantable c'est exactement ce que
voulaient les assassins alors il y avait
tout était sur table des coups tous les
écouter la la la maison était
entièrement sur table dès août la fff
via la cia et même la mafia avait posé
des micros partout tu me verras tout et
puis bien des années plus tard quand
quelqu'un a acheté la maison en question
il fallait procéder à des réparations
plafond et c'est là qu'on a découvert
des états de deux micros de deux fils
partout des gens qui écoutent et uta et
maintenant elle est beaucoup plus fin
que ça on arrive à bien planqué les
micros à l'époque ce n'était pas juste
un petit truc c'était impeccable partout
des émetteurs partout non voilà donc cet
assassinat d'après votre thèse
évidemment qui n'engage que vous
évidemment mais en tous les cas
marilyn monroe aurait été assassiné pour
mettre les kennedy dans la merde quoi
finalement
et non pas par les kennedy voilà c'est
ça c'est ça que vous dites alors dans ce
livre vous parlez aussi de caissettes de
cassettes sont enregistrées par maryline
ralph greenson le psy
de marilyn monroe la voyait en séance de
thérapie jusqu'à deux fois par jour mais
comme elle était toujours bloquée comme
on n'arrivait pas à bien se raconter
il lui avait dit bah écoute et
enregistrez vous si l'allaitement en
même temps mais bon enregistrez vous
tout seul avec un avec un magnétophone
ce qu'elle avait fait et donc
aujourd'hui vous dites-vous en tous les
cas avoir des informations qui remontent
à ces fameuses bandes magnétiques par
l'intermédiaire de quelqu'un à qui elles
ont été racontées je dis bien que ces
cds récit on est bien d'accord
c'est cela le psychiatre
ils ont été interrogés par le ministre
hajo de justice le procureur
quand il a tenté il lui a dit ban ou
marlene s'est pas suicidé alors vraiment
c'était pas très concluants et puis
surtout pour un psychiatre c'est bon ça
la fout mal quand son camp son client se
suicide
alors il ya des bains il m'a dit voilà
il lui a dit plutôt écouter ses
cassettes et si vous les écoutez vous
serez convaincu yen ne s'est pas suscité
alors il les a écoutés soigneusement il
a pris des notes et moi j'ai eu accès à
la transcription de la casse est la
personne qui écoutait ses cassettes
voilà c'est donc des retranscriptions
finalement non attester d'un
enregistrement présumé à liège c'est
vrai c'est vrai je veux enfin quand même
disons qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
semblent aller dans le sens de haut
la preuve les critères seul qui m'a
tenait des transcriptions est devenu
avocat
très respecté quelqu'un de crédible
c'est quand même alléchant jeunesse
deuxièmement pourquoi aurait-il monté
cette affaire de toutes pièces il
n'avait aucune raison de faire croire
que ces pièces étaient authentiques si
elle ne l'était pas et puis enfin si
l'on lit ces retranscriptions à on voit
ce que d'autres personnes ont dit et
cela correspond exactement au discours
de marine
mathiot soyaux et c'est une pierre de
banque d'investissement toi tu as pas
rater là j'ai gagné là laurent il alla
il ya dès qu'il voit un bon client je
donne sa carte absolument c'est très
gentil alors on apprend quoi dans votre
bouquin à matthew smith
on apprend que marilyn monroe était
super admiratif de john fitzgerald
kennedy ma points absolument
inimaginable elle dit marilyn monroe est
un soldat son commandant j'aimerais un
premier de la graine les filles son
commandant en chef est l'homme le plus
grand et le plus puissant du monde voilà
donc elle était très amoureuse de de
kennedy on en a la preuve à travers les
attraits des bandes
elle parle de son mari joe dimaggio
qu'elle a qu'elle a aimé beaucoup qui
est un un joueur de baseball joe
dimaggio qui était le seul d'ailleurs
qui est venue à son enterrement mais ça
pouvait pas marcher entre eux parce que
lui il voulait une épouse traditionnel
un petit peu
comprenez pas que sa femme soit une star
c'est ça l'histoire qu'elle soit la
bonne femme au foyer avec le tablier si
face à la cuisine à la maison qui
reprises les chaussettes et ça ça lui
plaisait pas trop
cela étant tout semble indiquer
lorsqu'on lit encore la fois des
transcriptions qu'elle comptait revenir
vers joe dimaggio et il a même été dit
qu'ils allaient se remarier le mercredi
qui a suivi en fait la ferme et parce
que c'était intérêts à la voilà donc
c'est vrai que joe dimaggio tout va qui
séduit des madiot c'était le point fixe
un petit peu de marine monroe elle parle
d'un autre de ses hommes
arthur miller grands auteurs dramatiques
américain en fait elle dit en parlant de
lui la chose ne l'intéressé pas beaucoup
le sexe était pas le truc d'arthur
miller c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles ça se passait mal
et alors elle dit je simulais un plaisir
exceptionnelle pour qu'ils se montrent
plus entreprenants
voilà alors il ya une histoire de
manquer un scoop énorme est ce que je
sais pas si nos téléspectateurs se
souviennent de john crawford john
crawford c'est une actrice qui jouait
dans johnny guitar qui était très haut
masse comme ça qui avait des cheveux
courts noirs qui étaient très très très
masculine et effectivement on apprend
que cette john crawford a une liaison
homosexuelle avec marine monroe et à un
moment un lotus août dessus un petit peu
comme vous avec votre notre hauteur et
et crawford lui saute dessus elle fonce
entre jeu parce qu'elles font exactement
mais elle dit en tous les cas
crawford john crawford a eu un
gigantesque orgasme et elle a crié comme
une folle c'est dans son livre en attend
excusez moi à matthew c'est dans la
version anglaise de son livre dans la
version française ça a été supprimé au
portugais diogo que les poêles aussi
marilyn monroe était était curieuse et
voulez tenter l'expérience je sais que
les gens se posent la question est de
savoir s'ils étaient tentés par les
organismes et puis en fait là
effectivement on le sait des lésions
directement de l'intéressé qu'elle avait
essayé mais ça n'a pas plu non c'est pas
plus elle n'a pas voulu recommencer à
faire l'amour avec shawn crawford et
dit-elle l'autre est devenu
malveillantes son endroit
elle a pris un petit peu en grippe à
cause de sa voix et lorsqu'on apprend
aussi en lisant votre livre enfin c'est
ce qu'elle a dit en tous les cas dans
ces bandes c'est qu'elle ne connaissait
pas l'orgasme marilyn monroe 1 c'est
tout à fait c'est tout à fait exact
et c'est assez étonnant pourrait-on
croire avec comme m
enfin et c'est là justement qu'elle a
été très reconnaissante à son psychiatre
qu'il a décoincé sur ce chapitre
marilyn monroe ne connaissez pas
l'orgasme et son psychiatre du a
expliqué qu'un orgasme ce produit non
pas dans l'est dans les parties
génitales je dirais mais dans la tête
voilà mais elle savait pas ça elle
pensait que lorqu'on se situer
vous pensez quoi fabien vous au litre à
10 heures la rue badeaux sérieusement
l'orgasme il est situé où leurs gardes
dans la mêlée
par exemple à travers le jeu vrai et
puis vient la tête aussi je crois ce
qu'a raconté le psychiatre
je crois que c'est armande altaï qui va
nous départager armand moi je crois que
marilyn était tellement gentil elle
voulait tellement faire plaisir
elle était trop préoccupés par le
fantasme qu'elle vous les procurer oui
je pense que c'est ça qui est juste allé
jusqu'à lui bloquer tout je pense
qu'elle voulait pas perdre le contrôle
parce qu'elle voulait surtout être aimé
et surtout faire plaisir mais ça ne
répond pas à la question côté d'eux mais
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'aux
états unis il ya plein de bouquins comme
ça de théories sur les complots les
conspirations ils viennent très souvent
des best-sellers et alors les américains
finissent par croire force de lire des
bouquins
excusez moi comme le vôtre ils finissent
par croire que saddam hussein est liée à
oussama ben laden qu'il vient semer fin
j'avais un mécène possède des armes de
destruction massive
est-ce qui a pas en ce moment comme ça
un dérapage général en amérique sur
toutes ces théories du complot de la
conspiration non dans la bay manny bon
disons qu'il ya eu beaucoup de livres
mais pas de nombreux people et crédible
c'est à dire que les gens présentent
leurs idées mais enfin elles sont
fondées sur rien du tout donc
ici c'est un peu différent parce que au
contraire le livre s'appuie quand même
sur des éléments concrets
wada bateau capter avec plaisir
l'ex-miss moi sur mes capacités
milk faut avoir du lait
vite bien merci à vous pensez quoi de
cette histoire là c'est une théorie
comme toutes les autres
il va croiser des dissidents de l'acier
pensez quoi de la théorie de matthew
smith
je pense qu'à chaque fois qu'on soulève
un coin du voile on est loin de la
réalité mais marilyn ou la plupart des
gens qui se suicident c'est presque
toujours des assassinats très réussi
j'écris une chanson sont arrivés à bon
port à quoi j'ai rêvé de toi en noir de
son mari les maris les que me dit que
marc levy marley
camilla matthew merci d'avoir été
l'effet d'un cran il n'a pas baissé mais
il n'a pas bu santé qui va l'emporter
swing aussi forte liu
et c'est une maison bleue adossée à la
colline
on y vient à pied on ne fera peut pas
jeter le lundi au soleil encore pendant
que nation comme on dit dégage en
anglais et aux médias
je suis
révélation de mari
hello bye keep it clean j'étais vidé
mais acheter une théière
merci c'est très sympa merci et
maintenant
voici ses miss la smera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la mouna plait pas vous que la voile
c'est à dire ce soir stanislas merhar
fabien galthié franchement on peut pas
faire beaucoup mieux à vous regarder
tout de suite sinon une alliance comme
si cette jeune eh bien pas bien tu veux
permettrait s'il te plaît arrête au
milieu ça va la calmer ouais bien 119
cela alors vous a découvert dans
nettoyage à sec excellent film de anne
fontaine où vous semer la confusion dans
un couple propriétaire d'un pressing
avec cette fameuse scène de sodomie avec
charles berling
alors moi j'ai vu le film j'ai adoré le
film je vais adorer
mathilde seigner aussi d'ailleurs
activement été formidable ensuite il ya
qu un truc c'est que franchement on
voyait que vous étiez pas des
professionnels de la sodomie avec
burning passionnant honnêtement la
province était pas dans l'axé c'est pas
ça c'est que la première fois non mais
la première fois ça peut pas se passer
aussi facilement que ça
ah bon 1 tu as plus de sérieux que vous
avez combien de prises pour cette scène
culte 4 4
ouais quand on tourne ça qu'est ce qu'on
se dit après avec berling vous dites
quoi là une faille entre les entre les
quatre entre les prises c'est avant ses
dix des treize jeux c'est considéré
comme une cascade sérieusement
sérieusement j'ai enlevé vous fait des
plaisanteries d'enlever des
plaisanteries du genre tu as un beau cul
je ferai ça moi j'essaierai de détendre
l'atmosphère a besoin c'est un beau cul
tu sais je rentrais une bouteille bien
en tous les cas ce film vous a valu à
nice l'as le césar du meilleur espoir
1998 ensuite les jean claude brisseau
manuel de oliveira avec la led chantal
akerman avec la captive benoît jacquot
adolphe mais voilà vous avez été battu
par benoît magimel pour la pianiste deux
années que et aujourd'hui vous revenez à
la fiche de merci docteur ray d'andrew
litvak avec dianne wiest jane birkin
bulle ogier et roschdy zem voilà
breakfast l'histoire dans l'histoire
c'est bien vous êtes homo une fois de
plus il faut être plus excusez moi mais
vraiment vous prenez rendez-vous
téléphonique avec avec des hommes et
l'un d'eux vous demande de vous cacher
dans le placard aux états unis ça veut
dire être homosexuel voilà ça turbine de
close up et on dira claude screen ça
veut dire une reine de placard une folle
de plaka aux états unis vous êtes caché
dans le placard effectivement vers nous
en france un joli re des chasseurs qu'on
voit plus rien q vous êtes caché dans le
placard effectivement et vous assister
non pas à une scène d'amour mais un
meurtre par poignard d'âge dans le dos
comme ça voilà tu es sur ce après avoir
vu ça vous rentrez chez vous vous
réfugiez auprès de votre mère et vous
apprenez à ce moment là que votre père
n'est pas mort d'homme accident de
voiture mais qu'il a été poignardé dans
le dos dans une chambre d'hôtel donc là
vous allez voir un psychiatre le fameux
docteur ray mais il vient de mourir
c'est incroyable scénario complètement
psychanalytique le psychiatre diane
j'arrêterai après il vient de mourir il
a été remplacé par jane birkin et là ça
devient un tourbillon absolument
incroyable film intéressant ça change
cette comédie qui changent break
différentes
c'est un truc à l'américaine fait à la
française et à la française fait à
l'américaine on voit que c'est un
américain qui a filmé paris un espace à
paris
ça donne ça donne un truc étrange aux
filles ça change un petit peu quoi
tables bancs bihan stanislas merhar
merci laurent et on va en profiter pour
regarder à quoi ça je commence à
comprendre par les mains des saints moi
je suis surtout très branché par tous
les trucs qui font mec entre mecs qui
font mec tu vois des trucs très mec mais
qui si vous me parliez de vous j'ai
peut-être une solution allez voir merci
docteur se munir de moi
notre invité ce soir bien alors ce qu'il
faut dire quand même un stanislas merhar
c'est qu'avant ce film c'est la première
fois que vous êtes resté aussi longtemps
sans tourner depuis que vous êtes acteur
évidemment vous dites j'ai l'impression
que quelque chose s'est cassé en moi
peut-être ce que je dégage n'est pas
terrible qu'est ce que c'est cette perte
de confiance subite là je suis un peu le
dernier fils michel deville way un monde
presque paisible way le dernier jour du
tournage
michel deville qui est monsieur c'est
bien alors l'animateur dit c'est ton
dernier plan de cinéma depuis sa filmo
il m'a dit ça gentiment il m'a dit c'est
ton dernier plan de cinéma toi tu dis à
kruth arrêté c'est le cas chez moi je
vais vous dire que dans mois s'achève la
croire quand sa maman l'attendait là
j'ai une spécialiste harmonie
l'évaluation des coups de mou là il a
des yeux tristes
ouais c'est beau crise non il est
typique typiquement le héros romanesque
vrai il a le regard de jacques dutronc
un peu vain la perfidie elle est bonne
qu'est ce qu'elle est bonne en
évaluation même sens ouais non mais
c'est vrai manque de confiance en vous
un petit peu stanislas en ce moment moi
ça vient d'où cette manque de confiance
ça vient de la musique
donc c'était quoi ton enfance bah il a
fait de la musique du piano piano
beaucoup beaucoup ensuite il a quitté sa
ils en avaient ras-le-bol
il a fait de la dorure marans avec tes
parents t'ont quoi tes parents comme
métier a man legends east et papa paicv
vue il avait une société de production
de cinéma en slovénie et l adolescence
était alors en conflit avec 16 ans par
là
pourquoi n'en faut s'occuper de lui ce
garçon là bas je place je suis bien
placé je pense que vous êtes très bien
placé non mais j'aurais vous dites je
suis toujours sur le fil
et finalement quand je joue ça peut
basculer dans le juste comme ça peut
basculer dans le à chier il avait cette
espèce de sans arrêt quoi de doute très
profond malaise c'est pénible riz et
parce qu'on a envie de refaire des sept
blessés les scènes à chaque fois quoi
j'ai je me force à dire non je vais pas
demander aux mecs de refaire 50 prise
merci au point en face à la bombe ont
alors fait interdire leurs feuilles bien
sûr wallers arabi peut être mieux bien
sûr
alors vous êtes toujours sur le faisait
toujours sur le fil stanislas merhar et
vous dites ça peut basculer dans le
juste comme ça peut basculer dans le h y
est à chier
l aimons bien méchant il a commencé
juste il a fini à chier c'est très
bizarre allez troisième prise le soir 3
diable donc c'est nice la smera revisite
je suis toujours sur le fil finalement
quand je joue ça peut basculer dans dans
le juste comme dans le à chier ce qui
est terrible c'est que vous aimez pas
votre image par exemple quand on dit je
vous le dis mouna quand on dit à
stanislas qu'il est un véritable jeune
premier qu'il a un beau ténébreux qui
les romantiques comme vous l'avez du
talent jean ray hé ben salem ça vous
aimez pas non mais à cause du piano
voilà la musique a été extrêmement
importante dans sa vie
je préfère je préfère et hélène grimaud
la ouais en fait on m'avait pas fait un
un truc comme ça là un triomphe romain
est aux frais du bien un triomphe romain
havrais louis penser que vous le méritez
pas non elle le mérite et quand j'ai vu
l'émission il ya rarement des besoins de
musiciens classiques
ouais et ils ont pas vraiment de place
dans le monde
c'est vrai et elle a pas eu de triomphe
romain et croyez moi qu'elles le
méritent
son album s'appelle credo mesdames et
messieurs c'est après puisqu'on peut
faire des spéciales et ducasse moi je
pense que garcimore a fait une carrière
magnifique s'est quittés trop tôt et que
plus personne ne parle de lui je
voudrais qu'on passe un triomphe romain
garcimore
bien par six morts
c'est que vous n'aimez pas ce pourquoi
on vous aime
puisque je voulais qu'on donnait des
concerts ont même pour ça ouais alors
effectivement je dis que vous n'aimez
pas ce pourquoi on vous aime parce que
tout commence avec une certaine céline
rencontré quand vous aviez 11 ans à nice
là c'est le disant et puis un jour quand
vous avez 18 ans votre père meurt vous
êtes triste et elle vous aime encore
plus et vous dites que votre malheur est
devenu à ce moment là une forme de
séduction
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui quand on lève
pour son côté triste son côté comme ça à
peu ténébreux ça le fait flipper ça
vient de la ce se refuse d'être aimé ça
vient du fait d'avoir été mais au moment
où vous étiez triste ouais j'ai trouvé
grossier de tomber amoureux de moi parce
que j'avais ce malheur ouais il est donc
aujourd'hui toutes les filles qui vont
vous aimez en vous voyant pas ce que ça
va être énorme
maintenant parce qu'il ya cinémania
tooway des psys qui protestent ils
disent qu'on gâche le métier non mais là
on va recevoir les psys là on va
recevoir dès lors on va recevoir d'état
gmail de deux filles qui vont être folle
de vous parce qu'elle vous trouve un
petit peu triste et ça vous voulez pas
mais si il n'a pas le dire parce que
c'est comme ça qu'ils attrapent mais
c'est un super bon calcul
ces garçons est très très fort avec
césar de cocker et doit appeler grave il
ya eu ces lignes a eu cécile qui vous a
quitté pendant le tournage du de ville
et vous dites j'ai jamais autant pleuré
et là les filles vous aime encore plus
cher qu'à chaque fois que vous annoncez
que vous êtes malheureux vous comprenez
bien que ça déclenche encore plus
d'amour je les fichiers aussi ouais
c'est dur devrait se poser comme ça si
jeunes en fait tu veux qu après céline
et cécile on passe à kolin tu tu veux
qu'on parle un peu d'elle ça te ferait
du bien tu as un dossier bah oui sur la
connaît bien qu ici mais je trouve qu'il
est parlant plutôt de celle de beaucoup
d'humilité
non tu crois que ça tu crois que c'est
un genre qui se donne toi non je les ai
vus dans les coulisses il était hyper
stressée non je crois que c'est un bon
acteur la presse que tout le monde dit
qu'ils y clip un peu trop et voilà un
bon c'est pas méchant non faudrait pas
qu'ils se foutent en l'air tout voir et
c'est ça on est inquiet pour lui c'est
sûr il faudrait pas que les décisions de
laisser notre voie là mais voilà bien là
comment ça va là présentement qu'elle
est à présent les amateurs de felipe
revient à chaque fois je m'entraîne ma
future carrière ne fait à temps attend
attend attend c'est ça ouais c'est
michel leeb à la perfection
c'est une chance la halle est à présent
votre esprit là comment ça va la cmu si
je serai un peu faire un film au monde
un film voulait faire un film parce que
je sais pas si je suis capable encore je
crois que c'est pas un film tu vas
attendre toute ta vie qu'on me propose
des trucs si ça si ça n'arrive jamais
fait un film tu fais peut-être avec à
tbilissi je vais aller faire un vrai ah
bah voilà
armande évaluation immédiatement il
faudrait peut-être qu'ils jouent un rôle
de truands
des terreaux et éroder parce qu'ils les
idées dans un premier temps comment
est-ce que c'est des torturés par son
engin il est pas à sa place alors
attendez vous dites qu'il est torturée
par son angélisme
oui enfin moi je suis pas souvent
actrice mais lorsque je jouais fed dans
la journée si je riais je vais arrêter
tout de suite les héros faut pas que je
reste ce soir je vais mourir
et comme il porte un personnage
douloureux il a peur peut-être des
spectres en retz à cause de ça il est
bien non
bien alors écoutez pour remonter le
moral de stanislas merhar pour lui
donner la pêche
on va lui faire une interview cire
pompes
[Musique]
c'est issa smera vous êtes sans doute
l'un des meilleurs acteurs de votre
génération le meilleur le meilleur qui
pourrait vous succéder tiens ça le fait
rire et tout ça y est tu vois ça marche
toujours un petit coup de un petit coup
de polish vous êtes conscient de votre
charisme exceptionnel sainz classe g
problème de coiffure tient là pourtant
on fait tout ce qu'on peut et on essaie
d'être enlevé son côté alors tout paris
bruisse de vos exploits sexuels c'est
vrai que c'est un super coup et
stanislas juge slovène hills lauren à la
mona lisa est alors vous êtes très très
généreux il paraît que vous êtes très
tolérant très généreux c'est ça non mais
dites oui valoriser lieu
oui oui rassure moi t'as pas le gaz chez
toi
les places coûtent la tête dans le micro
on il a pas l'air bien savoir si on pas
plus que ça non extrêmement généreux
extrêmement tolérant extrêmement cultivé
oui cette joie de vivre communicative
c'est quand même quelque chose et
surtout très drôle
mais à la base ça a peut-être contre moi
en commun cette information
[Musique]
non et break non on va dire au revoir
mandat pourquoi
non non non je la garde lagarde on se
voit jamais sans déconner tu fais
comment vous en rendez vous lors de ma
chouette petit peu une chanson douce que
jon hamm
armande vous partez oui oh là là là là
là vous quittez laurent t'être fait pas
deux comme on appelle ça gérontophilie
j'ai 15 ans plus que toi toi même on
parle plus ça se trouve ce sera pas
sexuel on échange des idées on s'en fout
dix ans les armes s'ils touchent pas ah
non non j'ai déjà dit ça y est je vois
ce premier vrai gros chat tu 21 you what
a capté comme mon nom cinq minutes
armand dont on va parler dans les airs
plein de trucs sans déconner aussi tête
attend tout ça michel leeb bien hormones
vous restez un petit peu pour faire
plaisir à laurent vraiment quelques
minutes de plus à oublier
et maintenant
mais
mon dieu
vu son blog
voici sur vidal man
[Musique]
sa vie d'alma de monchoix rebelles
étaient bloqués
mettez vos milieu fabien comment ça va
être bien de l'extérieur
ouais t'as vu laurent milliat un petit
peu de vocations aussi de petits ledit
mouvement des cheveux c'est comme ça on
pourra paulo a heureusement très fort le
coiffeur merci comment on peut faire ça
c'est incroyable
il faut déjà beaucoup de chemin bien
vous connaissez tous le monde là un
petit peu
armande altaï qu'on ne présente plus
qu'a voulu rester parce que vous veniez
garamantes voulait s'en aller
oui et quand je vais à seulement 4 sauf
it gets où elle vient voilà il me dira
ligue des champions a dit je serai en
retard au château mais je remplis de ma
vie si vraiment elle m'a dit 'ce ya
sophie thalmann jaurès à les concerts
londoniens croise et war mandin d'une
seule pièce
cela me fait plaisir de voir un monde
pour de vrai ce que j'ai habité dans le
petit et joie tu vois tu as déjà fait
plaisir
vous avez sa smera soeur sourire qu'on
appelle
quand même
hélas très beaux yeux à moi je serai
déjà en tant que garçon je trouve très
séduisant je serai une fille et vous
connaissez mon oeil ou non oui c'est une
femme très généreuse 13,7 euros
ce soir-là plein dont 2,3 millions de
francs à arlette laguiller et elle m'a
donné beaucoup d'argent un truc sans
frontières voilà et c'est sur un très
bon place un drapeau mougins millions de
francs à tréguier coule sans frontières
je pensais un peu pareil parfois bien
alors comment ça va ça va sophie
thalmann donc un mètre 80 dell
grandissant et manon et ça ça déjà pour
moi c'est prohibitif mais j'ai mangé
beaucoup de soucis pour ça qu'une fille
soit plus loin à l'horizon c'est pas
possible j'ai à présent avec un garçon
bon comme si saint germain autre chose
donc sophie thalmann longtemps surnommé
la girafe ou la grande godiche ou babar
petit bar à cause des oreilles décollées
comme ils l ont jamais à plus bas bas
n'ont demandé si je captais mieux que la
radio passe en ce moment
non je sont prises c'est pas moi c'est
geneviève non non non ce que dit
geneviève au sujet de ce alors j'ai vu
geneviève hier laurent payet elle te
fais un gros bisou je serai peut-être le
déclic de la réconciliation car elle m'a
chargé de te faire un gros bisou laurent
de charge et de te faire un cadeau une
boîte de thon parle pas de ton pour les
miss as excellent la voilà il m'a dit
surtout tu lui donnes tu lui dis que
j'ai envie de la revoir que ces jours ci
je l ai pas rancunière j'aime mieux le
contenu ça c'est le passé et que sitôt
ouais c'est fini c'était des conneries
voilà bon ça va tout va bien maintenant
bien alors à moi le truc bien alors donc
la girafe en tous les cas ça vous a pas
empêché de devenir miss me à 20 ans
comme quoi rice meuse à 20 ans tu te
rends compte la progression semaine à 21
des miss france à 22
quelle carrière est la nouvelle miss
cameroun quand même la t2a n'avait pas
voulu et on descend 1997 et tant qu'élu
miss france avec cette fameuse petite
phrase jean pierre foucault qui vous
demandent voulais faire plus tard et
vous lui répondez prendre notre place
j'attends toujours et vous attendez
toujours 15 millions de téléspectateurs
ont été témoins de votre ambition je
dirais même de votre arrivisme d'une
certaine façon mais voilà et vous
attendez toujours foucault est toujours
là ouais ça me tue pas on s'accroche
tu l'appelles l'atteignent voilà alors
quand on a été miss france le reste ton
toujours je penserai à vis ben il ya
croisé les gens dans la rue
sur la france par toulouse est toujours
dans est toujours présent pour la paix
dans le monde toujours non mais quand on
est ministre on a sonné pour la paix
dans le monde
ok pour ça mais c'était un peu le même
discours pour tout les ministres d'être
toujours dans la misère c'est pas juste
quelque part et que tu me dises animaux
comme arlette et que tuer des animaux
pour faire des manteaux c'est
dégueulasse ça c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'il est mignonne mais ce moque de tous
croire non pas du tout je parte jamais
les vrais fous rires et portez jamais de
vrais faux en attentant laurent est en
train d'avouer qu'elle ne porte jamais
sa vraie fourrure nous continuer à
sourire toute la journée les pays
faisaient depuis miss france est la
preuve
j'ai été reçue mais on apprend un
sourire c'est vrai c'est vraiment à me
saouler vachement bien ouais c'est vrai
est ce que vous mettez toujours des des
talons avec des maillots de bain oui
toujours après une fois qu'on a été miss
france non tenues ouais non mais t'es
pas de talent que maintenant je marche
souvent ténue entrisme ouais quand on
vous offre des fleurs vous le rendrai
public systématiquement l'a rejetée car
pour moi vous les gardez vous bien
alors tous les cas madame de fontenay
que nous aimons beaucoup les iem
geneviève notre ami je n'ai pas dit il y
aura un avant et un après sophie
thalmann voilà c'était avant restée
invendue calibre et si bien dire parce
qu'effectivement pourrait également un
après cevital man puisque vous avez
publié l'envers du diadème notre ami
michel lafon dans le cirage en plein de
rires ouais moi je veux juste faire la
liste un jour on a déjà parlé donc bah
vous vous plaignez des fêtes locales des
foires gastronomiques des dédicaces
photos des mains au cul des à jacques
faciale c'était dans le rapport
j'avais le jeune amateur de miss france
donc je confonds n'y a pas que ça les
mains au cul la radinerie de geneviève
de fontenay qui vous aura de loire de
100 filles un jour vous vous êtes vous
invite à manger la fameuse boîte de thon
avec les biscottes sa série 7 g de
terrible s'est déjà dit n'exonère en
plus une bête de temps donc ensuite
après les miss france en 99 vous avez
présenté téléfoot vous en souvenez est
ce que vous savez ce que c'est un petit
pont par exemple un petit pot ouais bah
oui c'est quand on passe la balle entre
les jambes du foot voilà un bien bon un
grand pont alors quand on passe la balle
en dessous d'un grand fou voilà hat
trick vous savez ce que c'est un
hattrick le atrix est ce que c'est assez
un truc qui est très dur faire je sais
pas expliquer et à canal+
non c'est pas le coup du chapeau le hat
trick si mais c'est super dur à faire
sur extreme chance et connaît pas les
sabreuses j'ai passé super du raf
tu sais ce que c'est toi c'est marqué
trois fois mais ça peut être un basket
rugby en football thierry henry est très
forts pour ça
une aile de pigeon c'est ce que c'est
j'ai ce que c'est une aile de pigeon
oui tu as été hâtée les prix combien ya
deux cartons jaunes avant une expulsion
c'est toujours non carton rouge avant
une expulsion combien faut-il de carton
jaune avant d'être expulsé 1
vous êtes dur non c'est pas été à
téléfoot et justement j'étais pas là
pour parler de ça est clairement où
chacun s'arrange usées travail a pas
photo à combien ça coûte
aujourd'hui vous avez quitté tf1 non
c'est juste que ils n'ont pas proposé
une émission dans laquelle je me sentais
bien
effectivement alors on vous retrouve sur
paris première vous commenterez le 6
décembre 2003 l'élection de miss monde
oui en chine 50 moi je reste ici
l'élection de jean nom sera ici à paris
je commenterai avec christophe roux il y
aura une rediffusion le lendemain dans
l'après midi à 14h30
on est aussi sur rtl on est en tout cas
c'est ce soir à quel point vous c'est
moi la fois encore plus écouter la radio
voilà et vous faites aussi des
commentaires d'équitation oui je
commence dimanche prochain sur sport +
demain
sophie thalmann franchement qu'est ce
que vous connaissez au cheval belge et
j'ai personnellement un cheval s'appelle
auteuil et alors je lui murmure tous les
jours à l'oreille en l'humain
c'est un cheval enfin cela
tu veux commenter
or on me disait très justement moi je
vais aux champignons je vais pas aux
truffes 1 2 par la bien vous êtes prête
avec un grand mère de christian vadim
s'appelait ardilouze et benoît haute de
verdun entendu ça la semaine dernière
dans l'émission et il m'a envoyé un mail
avec une idée d'interviews qui s'appelle
l'ardilouse
[Musique]
bon l'ardilouse c'est que des trucs de
luz votre pire passage télé à part suis
là ce soir c'est des gars c'était le
dernier
votre pire cuite jamais en danger une
phobie
du vomi donc jamais je me fait mal assez
bien ça c'est bizarre c'est une chance
bachar est resté quand la champagne ce
soir bien et vous je vous demande pas
c'était la veille de la demi finale
vous avez vu le résultat le résultat
bien votre pire mais avec sophie pire
n'est qu'à 20 janvier ouais bah ce
serait ça merci xavier de fontenay dans
ce serait qui le pire de tout ça serait
celui avec eux on apprendrait que qu'il
a déjà quelqu'un ça vous est arrivé ça
déjà qui t'a fait là c'est un mec de la
télé ça dans la 1re étape
non mais s'ils passent leur ans à mèze
un mec de la télé
non mais très connu peu de pire souvenir
magali pierre de vos choix et ses
ministres comme celui dans lequel le
l'hôtel campanile éléphanteaux non un
truc
bon c'est pas vraiment pire mais les
l événement on se demande qu'est ce qui
fonde à moi c'était comme un salon spa
ferment l'agriculture mais c'était le
storm qui la lie aux seconds à demander
toute sa vie non mais on était dans la
boue il faisait super froid et jeu au
milieu des vaches c'est à part aux
glaces voilà on est à un moment donné on
s'est fait la main votre pire expérience
homosexuelle
y'en a pas il a toujours été réussi non
mais je travaille donc ça veut dire
votre pire moment avec geneviève de
fontenay bassesse était en fait on
n'était pas ensemble mais c'est ce qui
s'est passé de parts après la sortie du
livre tout ce qui a été dit est un
moment assez dur à vivre
le moment le plus moyen de toute ta
carrière maintenant
[Musique]
il
armand genou et armande a décidé de
rester jusqu'à maintenant parce que
maintenant on a une chanteuse un peu
comme elle donc ça va c'est pas
doublonner
[Musique]
et
on m'apporte un coussin pourquoi parce
que j'ai l'air ridicule
ouais je suis dit qu'on est un peu oui
c'est vrai bottin ou d'eux mêmes la
province je m'en fous c'est pour être
ridicule c'est pas pour regarder
ah oui les ménines ça donne confiance
tu vois stanislas il suffit de rien tu
buzz
et maintenant
[Musique]
voici 6 me la peur
ah ah
[Musique]
simulateur bonsoir bonsoir dans les
français méritent pas très mal très mal
vient alors la meilleure façon de
présenter cindy lauper c'est ça
[Musique]
battant
ma
s
[Musique]
et du mans
m
[Musique]
ja
ainsi aux jo
à tort
non
à
[Musique]
finie la peur voilà ça c'est et satiété
la carte de visite
alors
après tout ça vous revenez aujourd'hui
cindy avec un album intitulé atlas qui
est une reprise de deux grands standards
très bien orchestré et très bien chanté
didier
je
thomas
sa mère
k
[Musique]
when i au sec
go
ça
ce sous
3m coeur
sama
mais les caisses des banquiers
[Musique]
à malley malo météo
non
[Musique]
malo mettez pas au vin
un livescore
m
[Musique]
ouais
un homme s'appelle ma classe
non
ouais
bravo cindy pas 25 message pour dire que
c'est beau un disque on passe à la bonne
vitesse
comme quoi les gens ici pour moi alors
c'est quoi c'est bien bon c'est pas
celle c'est bon alors qu'ils avaient
déclaré vous avez déclaré
si ni la peur je voulais simplement
faire la musique que j'entendais pendant
mon enfance dans mon quartier voilà
effectivement c'est assez réussi je dois
dire alors votre quartier c'était le
queens à new york où vous avez une
enfance un petit peu difficile avec une
mère divorcée des grands parents
maternels immigrants dit cali et vous
dites ils ont trimé toute leur vie ses
grands parents comme des malades pour
que leur fils soit digne de vrais beaux
américain est en fait ils y sont jamais
arrivées visite le rêve américain
c'était juste une illusion pour eux
ensuite en france dans des écoles
catholiques
vous avez été brimés par apport des
bonnes soeurs dont vous dites qu'elle
était rongé de frustration et qu'elle
était extrêmement perverses avec vous
tiens balayé c'est vrai mais j'ai réussi
à me faire virer donc finalement il ya
un dieu ouais vous vous dites que les
bonnes soeurs deviez l'impression qu'on
vous étiez leurs élèves qu'elle avait
été formé par les nazis tellement elle
était dure
oui le seul le votre seul plaisir à
l'époque c'était là c'était la chorale
vous dit quand je chantais avec la
chorale j'étais un ange et je chantais
pour dieu c'était le seul moment
finalement vous aviez un petit peu de
bonheur
je dirais que ça va ça va alors là ça
commence à 9 envoûté nier les cheveux en
vert pour la pour la saint-patrick ses
premières tarif est oui c'était pour
cette fête
peu importe j'aime bien faire la fête à
10 ans vous découvrir le rock avec les
beatles à 12 ans première guitare et là
vous commencez effectivement durant
votre adolescence à avoir les cheveux
multicolores des fringues absolument
excentrique et vous devenez un petit peu
là la dengue du quartier on peut dire
6000 hopper c'est vrai quand vous
arriviez à l'école les gens vous jeter
des pierres
ça c'est quand je rentrais de
l'université il me lançaient des pierres
effectivement ça et moi j'aimais bien
ses habits vintage mais c'était pas très
à la mode à ce moment là et puis
finalement quand on me lançait la
première paire pierre et bien je
répondais donc c'était c'est un petit
peu de ma faute et alors la maison c'est
très dur vous parlez de votre beau père
en le comparant à freddy vous dit quand
il était là on savait jamais si fait que
j vous foncez s'enfermer dans la chambre
ah ouais ouais mais ce que je voulais
dire par là c'est qu'en fait il était
une combinaison entre c'est ce que je
voulais dire par là il est entre les
deux freddy ça pourrait être n'importe
qui à l'époque vous touchez un petit peu
à la drogue au moment de l'adolescence
procurer j'ai changé je suis traité
simon blais avant de commencer à chanter
et je crois que chacun près un moment ou
un autre mais bien une question allez-y
j'ai entendu cette année cela ce rire
non je te jure j'ai entendu son
réservoir précis où tu as dit le mot
drogue
il ya peut-être une
je suis ta ferrero stan jeu passé comme
ça non mais attendez la drogue
son talent a dit oui ses fils et
stanislav stan et oliver c'est une miss
là c'est bien sûr alors à 16 ans cindy
lauper vous quittez le quartier du
queens avec votre chien sparkle et vous
fuyez comme je rêvais de pouvoir chanter
et puis j'ai réussi à le faire et et
voilà et donc ces dix ans plus tard que
vous sortez votre premier album solo
she's the usual 4,5 millions
d'exemplaires vendus seulement aux usa
vous devenez une énorme star
immédiatement alors c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque vous étiez quand même une bad
girl
aujourd'hui vous reprenez des standards
sais pas vraiment hollande bordeaux donc
à l'époque j'étais une bad girl
aujourd'hui vous êtes plus cool quoi
vous chantez des grands standards de la
chanson américaine
alors pour vous rappeler l'époque vous
étiez une bad girl
cindy lauper ont offert une interview
batgirl
[Musique]
cindy lauper de batgirl interview à quel
âge avez vous fumez votre premier joint
ainsi mme dié fois tu m'énerves jeu
direct 14 ans et demi vous avez vu
combien de petits copains dans votre vie
en finale moyenne et ce avec lesquels je
suis rassuré mais sérieuse n'est sérieux
bon j'avais 15 ans
sérieux times contenait un petit antoine
et autour de visites des bateaux devant
j'aurais adoré faire ça dansait dans un
western manipule aisément et non jean
aimé faire ça mais je peux pas vous avez
eu 20 petit copain sérieux et si on
compte tous il faut ajouter 1 0 forti
moi ça va non c'est beaucoup 46 vols
normaux combien pas des copains des
copines c'est pas énorme 40 alors
combien my wife sine die combien de
petits copains en même temps votre
record
non on va dire 3 combien de petites
copines arménie girlfriends ouais j'ai
essayé 9 heures
tu es lesbienne dans ses bottes quand
elle avait 20 ans mais pas moi ce
n'était pas moi cynique est la pire
couleur que vous ayez eu pour vos
cheveux à paris nice 1 1 dix mois on
arrive 91 je voulais atteindre mes
cheveux afin que véritablement on y va
d'un jaune à l'image mais
malheureusement pour moi ça s'est très
mal terminée et je dirais que ça que
lacoursière couleurs que joe lando
colombo peu verdâtre ça ne colorent
hollande au sine die non non non non
cette couleur est un mail à la couleur
que je pars toujours du très bien cindy
le plus longtemps que vous êtes resté
sans vous l'avez faire du camping n a
touché sa durée de deux semaines
mais je me lavais dans un espèce de nice
fait des petites bassine avec le recul
et que la réponse était la drogue la
plus dure que vous ayez essayé à part le
succès ouah ouah nazis savez lorsque
j'étais petite
elle ne ment quartier on nous disait que
la cocaïne ce n'était pas très grave
devait pas dépendants comparativement à
l'héroïne
alors ils nous faisaient de la cocaïne
certains sont devenus dépendants mais
moi je faisais d'autres choses dont j'ai
réussi à m'en sortir
tu comprends le français oui à brest
après d'aînés restaurant reste allant
après effet dîné nos deux fois moins
d'énergie ce torrent ni wang fei si one
2 et 5
[Musique]
non
c'est noté
[Musique]
sanaa prime pas même l'appareil photo ne
croit pas ses deux doigts de conclure et
ça marche pas la preuve c'est pas de
pause d'abord donc cindy merci d'avoir
été avec nous thank you very much
et j accueille maintenant richard
labévière
[Musique]
et
salut à ma fille qui me dit il s'appelle
richard labbé pierre richard labévière
articule à la déconne bien vous être ça
va très bien vous allez bien là bien
donc pardon stan on va changer tu vas
prendre ma place tu vas dire des vannes
qu'est-ce qui se passe il va dire des
vannes et moi je vais faire la tronche
d'accord donc ma fille tu fais stanislas
les brèmes c'est lui la loupe pourri
j'ai envie de faire ce talent en même
temps je vais te faire linverse je suis
pas bien et toi donc scène tu fais des
vannes d'accord donc richard labévière
jetterait docteur en chef et
éditorialiste à radio france
internationale rfi
avant d'aller plus loin je voulais qu'on
ait une pensée pour un journaliste de
rfi qui a été assassiné à abidjan il ya
quelques temps jean hélène alors donc
pas tellement à votre à rfi vous publier
régulièrement des livres et notamment
chez grasset en 1999 un livre qui
s'appelait dollars de la terreur est
aujourd'hui toujours chez grasset vous
publiez les coulisses de la terreur
c'est un petit peu le prolongement du
précédent
car pour vous le 11 septembre 2001 n'est
pas un point de rupture mais en fait une
continuation d'un processus anciens de
rupture voilà alors le pitch de votre
livret est assez simple al qaïda
n'existe pas voilà c'est la phrase
finalement la plus la plus remarquable
de votre bouquin vous dit pour justifier
ses objectifs c'est à dire le pétrole la
guerre sans fin décrété par les
américains avaient besoin d'al qaïda
superbe invention médiatique pour vous
en fait al qaïda au delà de ce qui s'est
réellement passé
c'est un petit peu une création
des américains si vous voulez avant les
attentats du 11 septembre on n'a jamais
parlé d' al-qaïda alors que les
activistes salif sy salafistes le but de
cette idéologie a convergent des frères
musulmans et des wahhabites saoudiens
égorger des gens depuis dix ans en
algérie en egypte en asie du sud est
il faut rappelons que le premier
attentat contre le world trade center
c'est en 93
donc je veux dire les services
américains étaient parfaitement au
courant de qui étaient ces réseaux qui
les ont a souvent tu as lease et est
beaucoup utilisé dans la guerre contre
les soviétiques en afghanistan
si vous voulez tout est ce que vous
dites c'est évidemment tout ça existait
déjà et qu'en fait les américains après
le 11 septembre ont collé ce label cette
étiquette al qaïda sur sur ses réseaux
pour permettre en fait aux usa de
justifier un énorme déploiement
militaire et imposer leur vision du
monde
au reste de la planète en si vous voulez
le basculement s'est vraiment octobre
2002 les attentats de bali en novembre
2002 les attentats de mombasa et enfin
mai 2003 attentats de casablanca de
riyad avec les derniers attendaient
d'istanbul et là je veux dire al qaïda
et ben laden absolument rien à voir dans
ces attentats
c'est un peu un terrorisme local en deux
chaînes qui sont arrachés dans des
conditions économiques et politiques et
qui locales et donc qu'ils utilisent
al-qaïda comme un un label une référence
qui ne renvoie pas à une organisation
planétaire ce que oui ils veulent assez
à celui ci que al qaida et c'est tout
l'intérêt de votre livre richard whitt
qu'al-qaïda n'est pas structurée sur un
mode pyramidal internationale comme l'a
été à l'époque le komintern c'est-à-dire
l'internationale communiste
mais en fait ce sont de petits groupes
autonome et que le terrorisme dites-vous
s'est délocalisé ses quelque chose vous
l'avez dit qui a servi à l'armée
américaine qui a facilité le plus grand
redéploiement de moyens militaires ou
stratégiques américains depuis la wilaya
moyens et ça je veux dire il ya
dans la mesure où les américains
continuent à nous dire ben laden est
partout il faut mettre des soldats
américains partout pourquoi tout
simplement pour de l'influent
stratégique aux militaires et des
intérêts économiques
c'est un alibi c'est un alibi seuil
alors venu désormais nous vivons dans un
monde orwellien non qu'orwell 1984 le
monde la falsification médiatique de
masse la guerre sans fin contre le
terrorisme finalement c'est une
référence flou qui permet en fait
n'importe quelle aventure militaire
l'empiré américain depuis la fin de la
guerre froide et privés des demis
ouais c'est terrible pour un empire donc
il faut bien sans réinventer un autre
l'idéologie de la guerre sans fin si
vous voulez remplace l'idéologie de la
guerre froide est ce qui permet à l'
empire américain de se reconfigurer de
se redéployer de remettre des basses et
des soldats américains partout dans le
monde pour continuer justement à avoir à
continuer à avoir un ennemi et à faire
ce que dit monsieur bush et ses amis néo
conservateurs à poursuivre une guerre
sans fin contre le terrorisme la terreur
alors qu'en fait dites-vous le seul vrai
objectif c'est le le pétrole de l'asie
centrale ce que vous nommez le grand jeu
le nouveau grand jeu
c'est un des objectifs c'est pas le seul
critère c'est une des raisons est la
meilleure preuve dit vous c'est que
quand les américains sont rentrés dans
bagdad
ils ont laissé piller le musée de bagdad
où il y avait des les richesses
archéologiques des débuts d'humanité de
notre histoire est en fait le seul
endroit qui était réellement protégés
c'est le mystère sur la production
pétrolière voilà alors cette mainmise
américaine sur le pétrole irakien
dites-vous leur assurant fait une mamie
sur l'opep puisque maintenant il pèse au
sein de l'opep ce n'était pas le cas
avant s'ils voulaient moins sur les
réserves pétrolières que sur le contrôle
des cours du brut
or justement les usa depuis qu'ils
occupent l'irak sont moins tributaire
évidemment du pétrole d'arabie saoudite
et vous revenez sur les liens entre les
usa et l'arabie saoudite
les compromissions financière au plus
haut niveau et vous dit qu'un jour ça
risque d'éclater et vous parlez d'un ben
laden gay c'est vrai que le bin laden
guette aujourd'hui quand on travaille
sur ces réseaux et sur leur financement
parce que moi j'ai commencé à travailler
il ya douze ont sur les structures
financières parce que j'étais installé à
genève
je voyais passer les valises de billets
si vous voulez eh bien nous ramène non
pas à des banques forcément ce malienne
ou pakistanaises mais a de l'argent que
saoudien enchevêtrés en partenariat avec
de l'argent américain et nous ramène aux
grandes sociétés américaines du complexe
militaro industriel comme bechtel
halliburton new carlisle ces sociétés
qui actuellement sont en charge de la
reconstruction de l'irak et au conseil
d'administration de la plupart de ces
sociétés vous retrouver non seulement le
gotha du parti républicain est d'aider
des idéologues néoconservateurs de
l'administration bush mais vous
retrouver
bush bush père notamment au sein de
carlyle et d'anciens chefs de la cia
comme carlucci un lobby le build and get
c'est ça c'est que si vous enquêtez très
sérieusement sur le financement du
terrorisme
aujourd'hui vous revenez fatalement aux
états unis aux places offshore ou aux
îles anglo-normandes aux bahamas aux
îles caïmans à curaçao
c'est à dire un fonctionnement de
finances internationales dont au
personne surtout pas les américains
n'ont intérêt à lever le secret ou
l'opacité si vous alors bel laden
derrière vous confirmer une information
qui avait été donnée par le figaro et
puisqu'elle est pas été démentie
maintenant les gens n'aient pas beaucoup
donné suite
vous confirmez donc cette information
selon laquelle ben laden aurait séjourné
à l'hôpital américain de dubaï en
juillet 2001 donc deux mois avant le
wall trade center et il avait rencontré
comment la un patron de la cia locale
l'idée c'était finalement assez assez
clair c'était de dire à ben laden
écouter on vous donne la vie sauve vous
vous installez vous voulez à condition
que vous arrêtez finalement
vos actions donc ça veut dire que deux
mois avant le wall trade center vous le
vous le confirmer à votre bouquin les
américains ont proposé un marché à ben
laden tout à fait vous avez raison de
rappeler que cette information était
sorti en fin novembre 2001 dans le
figaro et sur les ondes de rfi
à l'époque on avait le factuel on savait
que tout ça a été confirmé aux
meilleures sources y compris par des
services secrets arabes de la région
donc on était parfaitement sûre du
factuel
on a fait pas le sens et la lecture de
ce séjour et de cette rencontre avec le
résident local de la cia à dubaï
s'appelle larry mitchell
on a on a relancé longue quête on a
refait une enquête de proximité à dubaï
avec ma collègue allaient alexandra
richards pendant de nombreuses semaines
et effectivement on a pu recouper avec
des témoignages de personnes travaillant
pour l'administration de l'hôpital
américain qui effectivement larry
mitchell le résident local l'a6 à dubaï
avait rencontré ben laden à l'hôpital
américain le 12 juillet 2001 pour
essayer si vous voulez de déboucher sur
un accord sur une ultime négociation
pour que les afghans arabe de la
mouvance ben laden dans le monde cessent
de s'en prendre à des intérêts
américains
ça ne s'est pas fait contre son retour
on a besoin dit je vous rappelle que ben
laden avait été privé de sa nationalité
saoudienne
en 94 si al qaïda était une structure
pyramidale comme le komintern liaisons
internationales
on pourrait discuter avec un chef et on
pourrait faire un deal ce que vous êtes
en train de nous expliquer là ce soir
c'est que finalement il ya tellement de
base d'al-qaïda dans le monde ya
tellement d'endroits où ou ce label est
revendiquée qu'on peut pas négocier en
fait et ce qui est très étrange c'est
que depuis le 11 septembre marqué dans
la presse du 11 septembre au printemps
2002 toutes les semaines on arrêtait un
cerveau d'al qaïda
wesley dû arrêter qu'un cerveau on a
donc s'inquiétant oui beaucoup à longvic
il ya eu aussi un cerveau moi c'est là
or quand on négocier avec l'ira ou avec
les farc selon hélène que l'on vienne
bon il ya une structure des questions à
poser à notre amie sophie non enfin moi
j'aimerais bien savoir comment ça va se
terminer mais bon personne ferait pas
richard labévière les folies zélateurs
merci
[Musique]
et
j'accueille maintenant bruno salomone
[Musique]
alors bruno salomone bonsoir tu arrive
juste après al qaïda ouais c'est clair
mais armes et des munitions ont été
assez flipper ailleurs super content tu
es content de ça m'émeut sam et
moustiques alors bon soir on s'est
connus avec ça
chaque fois ça ça donne un peu le
frisson cet été ses débuts contentant dé
sa graine de star tu disais ça il faut
que j'y aille à l'époque c'est le sketch
de la caissière la caissière la première
c'est comment la crise ya fait un petit
peu comme ça et comme ça je faisais des
choses et des sketchs quoi tu vois je
suis là je suis avec un truc jean bip
quoi toi ac oui c'est ça
c'est
[Musique]
et maintenant rien sa taille et de ta
mère tu sais qu est ce qu elle m'a dit
en mer alors ça ça ça c'est la cerise
sur le mac doute ça c'est la boulette
qui fait déborder le vase
un m'a dit qu'elle avait trouvés sous
ton sommeil bien à l'abri des regards
indiscrets
un disque de comédie musicale roméo et
juliette
roméo et juliette une dalle paix ou quoi
c'est quoi cette musique de barbares y'a
même pas
quand je pense que tu as été bercée au
scratch
ça me fait mal à la route
je dire moi je me perds contre toutes
les injustices de l'homme et de la terre
parce que moi j'estime canton comme
humain l'homme doit et par conséquent la
femme se doit
sébastien être les égos identique et
gally taurian est il de celle non
excusez moi mais quand j'entends encore
parler de sécrétions raciale ou 21e
siècle à l'ombre de l'anpm il
c'est pas un peu rétro leader c'est
évident je dire on est pareils on est
tous pareil alors acceptons nos
différences
non mais je dis est fait pour les
mélanges regard des milkshakes un moment
qu'on a tous regardé d'autres du nombril
et conques bouge le cul voilà bruno
salomone au bataclan nouveau l'être
ça va de fonte et derrière ça y est
hadji mois alors malgré malgré
l'importance qu'elle que j'ai eues dans
ta carrière carrément un sens indéniable
ah ben moi j'ai vécu des scènes mais sa
tâche mais ça doit pas empêcher de me
trahir quand même le très bas tu vas
voir qu'est ce que je fais bonjour
bonjour on va au bristol
je vais un téléphone portable s'il vous
plaît mais moi j'aime pas
bourriche
ça je fais quelque chose je m'attendais
non armés ont taxé
avec chf
avant mais c'est gentil qui va arriver -
10 moi je suis content parce que je suis
amoureux
autant qu avez-vous je suis content vous
savez où vous mais je ne sais pas vous
qui me soulez plus qu'à 26 personnes qui
m'attendait que
je veux pas que l'on va arriver à dubaï
ouais
26 personnes tf1 tout
à
ce soir
vous faites des toons peut tout me range
de chandelle de temps en temps mais je
tousse sérieux chandelle j'en étais et
41 je l'étais aux cards
j'aime danese je sais quel âge en fait
c'est une forme qu'une fois ça m'a fait
mal j'ai pas recommencer
continuez continuez sur les fans ces
femmes tiré ce changement c'est plus
loin thierry pierre clément way et le 6
janvier 1949 c'est plus loin stéphane
vous étiez au collège saint michel azzi
à la faculté de lettres de montpellier
fils de victor ardisson et de madame
juliette rené gastinel je pouvais pas
oublier tout cela
samedi dernier corti s'est déguisé il
s'est déguisé en enfant thomass haha tu
t'es fait [ __ ] thierry bienvenue à
taxi sur l'abc ça va bien
bravo
bruno salomone formidable à la sorte
échappé que c'est canal+
je suis en regardant les accies comme
par hasard mon portable il avait retiré
la puce je peux pu téléphoner jeté avec
toi ça a duré 40 minutes et pendant 40
minutes j'ai cru que tu étais un vrai
chauffeur de taxi fan de moi tu vois
alors on va faire maintenant une
interview si j'étais
[Musique]
salamone si j'étais un bruit un bruit
ouais pas rendre sa même pas les gentils
cycle des dents donc j'aimerais bien
être que j'aime paraîtra si j'étais un
animal un animal je pense que je serai
un hybride genre le faucon tôt par
exemple l'animal qui vole le plus vite
et qui voit rien un meuble une
secrétaire à légumes
doc gynéco un saint saint saint maclou
tâche déchire une bonne pour y jouer une
mauvaise imitation une mauvaise
imitation
je sais faire le bruit de la chaussette
quand on enlève des pieds par est sûre
ça fait c'est pas mal ça met une bonne
imitation une bonne je sais faire tu
sais avec la voix de joe dassin
vas-y tu sais à temps
comment serge on va le refaire et tuant
va le garder et vas-y fais-le pascal
comme ça tu le sais très bien alors un
motif d' embrouille un motif d'
embrouille qu'on pose trop de questions
ouais ouais là nos hommes politiques
bernard menez
ouais c'est pas une odeur une odeur la
pyramide du louvre pas ça sent bizarre
une infirmité laurent baffie nique
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant place au blind test didier
ce soir ça caille aux platines stéphane
pompougnac
[Musique]
stéphane pompougnac bonsoir donc vous
connaissez le principe du blind test
mouna tu connais le principe
fabien s'agit pas d'être quatrième là le
le blind test elle c'est très simple je
veux l'interprète voilà c'est tout un
d'accord l'interprète stanislavski ses
clips ou pas il ya des équipes au départ
c'est par équipes l'équipe de stanislas
merhar contre l'équipe de mouna ayoub
voilà et après c'est chacun pour sa
gueule quand on arrive aux banques aux
oméga beaucoup et c'est de tous les pays
moi je vois l'international près ça peut
être une chanson la punaise par exemple
celui attention premier morceau up
au noir
m
on a bossé
à
[Musique]
oh
bonnet que ça
merci
ban
tron est donc toi tu es donc je vois si
méline évidemment comme il a écouté le
soufflage
mais sa mère est ma chemise et merci
aum
emma tôt stéphane numéro 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
numéro 3 stéphane
l'eau
je rame savez ce qu'est ce que tu
attends je suis ailleurs tu dit jo
privat
celui-ci je sais je suis allé là c'est
donc hiroire du bas et pour que ce sont
des devoirs des os cassés malange tu
fous rien tu es chez toi toute la
semaine la chute chez moi dans ma tête
eu des doigts la maison le branleur rien
chez soi toute la semaine
lee
non
pire j'ai la place de stan je sais ce
que j'ai fait des petits mois ça fait
deux points pour eux et un point pour
eux seulement
c'est marrant ça j'aurais cru que
j'étais devant un bon attention ce temps
là on va changer stéphane
dans la demeure
je pense que fabien galthié
petit riff et
[Musique]
dans les moeurs non
[Applaudissements]
galtier fabien galthié tu vois comme
quoi ta place ont perdu finalement
fabien attention stéphane
numéro 7 gago charme tchad top 5
non non si s'échappent les i love
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc on est un 3 3 mai linh
effectivement on est à 3 3 et maintenant
attention
stefan wey bravo
alors lui j'étudie à un truc tu as bien
quand il les trouve
c'est la première note à séparer ses
skis sont privés veulent pas lui à la
première note
et
attention stéphane
son secret
ça
et
non
qui lui a dit tout à l'heure en s'auto
qu'il est dix heures
alors 4,4 là c'est chaud là olalala le
par équipes à se départager sur le
chanteur qui arrive maintenant puisqu'on
est à 4 4 le par équipes est très très
chaud attention stéphane sous la main
j'adore ce
[Musique]
là
1 80
non
c'est joe jackson -
[Applaudissements]
e
donc on est à 4 4 à la fin du par
l'équipe maintenant si chacun pour sa
gueule on va commencer avec le bongo
très très difficile ce soir
attention stéphane rose garden
donnant son nom
[Musique]
merci d'ailleurs
et ça
m
[Applaudissements]
odile guy mcknight qui chante odyssée le
remix à ces drames x10 et ça c'est de là
qu'il a écrit lé sénat écrit
pratiquement tous les tubes de la tamla
motown et il s'appelle vous ne savez pas
lamont dozier
et oui regardez bien ce logiciel marquer
hollande à londres et non ils ont écrit
tous les tubes des suprêmes tous les
tubes des fortes offs etc
on continue stéphane j
[Applaudissements]
wells a droit
[Musique]
oui donc jusqu'à présent ces lendemains
fille et maintenant donc il reste un
morceau c'est le méga bon qu le morceau
quel morceau qui n'entend super moins
bien ici en plus de critiques il est
mature que les méga bongo celui qui va
trouver celui-là aura tout gagné sinon
c'est laurent qui aura tout gagné
attention maintenant tu es fan
[Musique]
l'estran glace ouais d'accord
comment tu t'appelles manquait d'abord
merci franck legros gagnant bravo
non
[Musique]
pour l'odeur
merci monsieur pompougnac c'était
toujours en parle avec
bouna
soutient l'association dessine
à l'occasion de la journée mondiale
contre le sida le 1er décembre
fabien galthié calendrier de l'ucad
dieux du stade au profit d'associations
deux tomes dvd
hecking me casse
stade armande altaï
de loin chez jean claude lattès matthew
smith victimes
chez plon stanislas merhar merci de
coeur et de rendre au lido avec
stanislas merhar jianli chen
bien qu'ils purgeaient sort le 3
décembre
sophie thalmann commentera élections des
miss monde 2003 mais aussi descendre sur
paris première à 20h35 arlette bévière
les coulisses tu la terreur s'était
invité chez grasset cindy lauper sur
l'album s'appelle à clastres une
salomone le solomon reloaded au bataclan
tu oses décembre 10 janvier
mais un seul cd
à bruno salomone ovata cambia mimolette
voilà stéphane pompougnac merci l'album
s'appelle living dead remercie beaucoup
reporters sans frontières l'album débute
hughton pour la liberté de la presse au
prix de 8 aux produits des journalistes
emprisonnés dans le monde
howard rendez-vous à la semaine
prochaine ya le téléthon mais dans
quinze jours
[Musique]
oh
maman
[Musique]
j'attends qu'ils sont
moi aussi
[Musique]